at the end of time
[Music]
13. o'clock
well hey everybody here we are back
again on this Wednesday night it's
raining outside yeah we have a bummer of
topic I'm sorry to tell you yeah me and
Jim me and Jim are sitting here
discussing the outline of this case and
I'm just like man this [__] here [__]
gets me oh yeah it's pretty awful yeah
went to strangers it's one thing but
when it's like the kid's mom that's
doing it it's just like ah I mean I've
spent the last few days researching
these two cases and I'm gonna say right
now I was just telling Tom I was like
spoiler alert uh we'll just talk about
Susan Smith first
um I don't really feel bad for her uh
because of reasons I'll get into later
Andrea Yates though the more I read
about her
I was like that woman
um man she has some severe mental
problems and she really really tried to
get help for it and it just didn't work
out uh which we'll get into it a little
bit too so I kind of you know I'm not
justifying what she did or anything like
that because what she did was [__]
horrific but
um
All I'm gonna say is uh psychosis it's a
[__] and uh
she really should have got more help
yeah from that case what always got me
is that it's been a long time since I've
heard it but I remember somebody
saying what her testimony was about what
the children were saying why she was
killing them and I was just like oh man
yeah I like hearing about the the both
of the cases like the actual kids and
the Susan Smith one's pretty horrible
too like how they died because I could
imagine that and I was like holy [__]
[__]
awful the kids were trying to please the
mom and [__] beg for forgiveness and
[__] I was like oh
yeah it's terrible but yeah so what are
you gonna do you know what I mean if I
was there I'd try to save the kids
there's something about it where I like
like makes me mad like I wasn't there to
save it you know what I mean that kind
of [__] I don't know I think most guys
are like that probably most people are
like that you kind of get mad at
yourself that you weren't there in some
way to prevent it
yeah I feel that about a lot of cases
yeah read about to be honest whether
it's kids or I mean I guess especially
when it's more but yeah pretty much
anybody yeah that's kind of vulnerable
in any way right like you always kind of
feel like [__] man if only I'd been
there I could have done something you
know what I mean yeah I get that yeah
the perpetrator does it on purpose
though so you're not there so you can't
that's why they do it that way
Oracle says uh hierarchal by the way uh
on fun fact I was living in Charleston
the year Susan Smith murdered her sons
and worked just down the street from
MUSC where the autopsies were performed
uh that was a very creepy day the whole
city knew the boys were there yeah it's
uh [__] up and
um I don't think as far as I'm aware
like at the trial
because
um you know not to be gross or anything
like that but the kids had been in the
water for nine days
um and so their bodies were very uh
decomposed
and they were actually I think they were
actually going to show the photos to the
jurors but they ended up not showing
they basically just showed them like the
legs and stuff like that because they're
just like the whole thing would have
just been like too much that I mean that
would have just been a [__] image
that you'd never get out of your head
you know what I mean like obviously some
people had to really look at them but
they didn't uh they didn't end up
showing the entire photos to the jury
because they thought that that would be
too [__] up too prejudicials yeah well
that yeah that's that was the um that
was the thing that they used so the
thing now both of these women are still
alive uh Susan Smith is still in prison
she's actually eligible for parole next
year
in 2024 so we'll see how I'll never let
that woman out so we'll see how that
goes yeah and especially because she's
been a little bit of a um Troublemaker
in prison to be honest with you and
Andrea Yates is in a mental hospital
and does not appear to want to be let
out because they do actually like come
to her every so often and be like hey
you can make a petition like for release
and stuff like that and she always
waives the right to do that
so no she's got nowhere to go either
that too
um but I do feel like she
just from like kind of a a read-through
of what she was like I kind of feel like
she thinks that she hasn't been punished
enough yeah you know what I mean oh
there's no coming back from that one no
there's really not no
um and I'm gonna say too that I think a
lot of um I mean there was a lot of
factors that went into what happened in
that situation but I think one of the
factors was kind of an extremist
religious
I don't want to call it a cult although
it was very culty
um her and her husband were involved in
so and the beliefs of this religion were
maybe contributed to
what ended up happening like just the
whole situation that's not an excuse
though no I'm not saying no I just said
that that was a factor that probably
like contributed there was a lot of
things that contributed I think the main
thing she was [__] crazy
well I mean well no I mean she's very
mentally ill she is very mentally ill um
she had actually been uh diagnosed many
many times uh when she was younger and
she uh
her family also it ran her family um
suicide and stuff like which is weirdly
this uh similar to uh Susan Smith's
family too so these these two women they
in a lot of ways they're kind of similar
and interestingly the FBI
um evidently has a profile of mothers
who kill their children
and both of them
could be uh both of them like kind of
describe both of these women but the
thing about it is that I think there's a
difference in the motivation for sure
um because like I said I don't really
yeah Susan Smith had some mitigating
factors too but I don't really feel bad
for her because
she seemed to
despite what she said I think she had
more narcissistic reasons for doing what
she did whereas Andrea Yates was just
very very sick and had delusions
about her children and about herself and
things like that that uh contributed to
it so I mean I think Susan Smith kind of
knew what she was doing
whereas Andrea Yates I'm not really sure
like she knew what she was doing but I'm
not really sure
that she really thought through like the
consequences of what she did I guess you
know what I mean she wasn't in full
control there were faculties yeah and um
and a jury agreed later on uh they
actually did and this was in Texas which
has like really really harsh like it's
really really difficult to get an
insanity defense in Texas uh but she did
because her now her original conviction
was just life in prison
um but then it was overturned later for
a reason which we'll get into later
um and then the second jury actually did
find her insane like she didn't like she
knew what she was doing was wrong kind
of but she didn't like she wasn't in her
right mind like when she did it so they
uh just sent her to a mental hospital
which honestly like knowing what I know
about her is probably the best place for
her Mental Hospitals are worse than
prisons
you go in there [__] you're you're
gonna if you went in there saying you'd
come out crazy well she seems to be at
least according to a fairly recent
interview of somebody that like went and
goes to visit her
um they said she seems to be doing
pretty good
um but like I said she wasn't doing too
good on the outside like she was having
a hard time nothing Laguna ticks in
there
well she's at um
they transferred her yeah they
transferred her to like a lower security
one because they determined she's not a
risk to anyone yeah um but she doesn't
seem to want to get out she seems pretty
content where she's at
um and you know she has people come
visit her and [__] like that so like I
said it's just it's it's just a really
sad case all around and I think that in
that case it could have been prevented
Susan Smith I don't really know because
I I feel like she had different reasons
for doing what she did
did but um Camp guy said I gotta check
these gals out find out about their
backgrounds
yeah
um
I mean we'll get into it but if you want
to like do a deeper dive actually if you
go on Murderpedia
which is a real good uh site which has
like just lists and lists of all the
murderers not just serial killers like
all the murderers
um there's like a really really long
write-up of Susan Smith it's like a
[__] novel man so I read like all of
that I read all the [__] about her and
stuff like that the one about Andrea
Yates isn't as long but somebody did
write this big huge long like essay
about like did like a deep dive about
her life and her motivations and all
this other kind of stuff
Oracle says I can feel sorry for Andrea
Yates but Susan Smith I'd push the
button yeah I'm kind of on the same page
as you I remember that
um at first like I started reading about
Susan Smith and I'm like ah well she had
some kind of shitty stuff happen too but
like the more I read about her and like
the more that other people like said oh
she said this not the other thing I was
like yeah [__] her but you know what I
mean but Andrew it's I do kind of feel
bad for her even though I that is no way
justification for what she did because
it was horrible but
um she like I said she was severely
she's just a very very sick person it's
a very sick person
um
so yeah Camp guy says I'm lucky I've
been able to tame my own demons without
major upheaval anymore yeah I mean you
know
um all right let's see
yeah Oracle was saying that um she was
in South Carolina like when they were
doing the when the Susan Smith thing
happened she's like and then I moved to
Texas in time for the Andrea Yates case
we yeah it's like it was following year
around
High Desert 004 said some Christian
groups are more like death Cults yeah
the one that they that um Andrea Yates
and her husband were involved in was a
little bit like that it was like I said
it wasn't a cult cult but it was kind of
like a Street Preacher with followers
and he had like some really weird like
fundamentalist beliefs and they were
like really into that I mean her husband
Rusty was more into it than she was I
feel like but she was really into it too
and she was again and I feel like this
is this is kind of a common thing to
both of the women
is that they're both people Pleasers
um in that they wanted to do
particularly Andrea like she really
wanted to do everything to like make her
husband happy even though she maybe
didn't want to do that you know what I'm
saying but we'll get into that a little
bit too yeah Oracle said Susan Smith
worked too hard at first to pretend she
didn't do it yeah and if you watch see I
couldn't determine
because I was watching a documentary
about Susan Smith and they had like a
lot of uh footage of her because
obviously like I said after she first
killed her kids she very famously said
that a black man had carjacked her and
driven off with her babies
and she kept that up for like nine days
yeah and every cop was like that doesn't
sound right yeah they said the cops were
suspicious like pretty much from the
second day of the event car jackets go
well there was a lot of other factors
too but if you watch footage of her like
because she was in she was all over the
media like her and her husband like
crying about
you know bring our babies back and stuff
like that like in the whole time she
knows they're dead and I don't know if
it's just because I know that she killed
them
but Hershey is so fake yeah she's like
she
um
like that like she said like she stopped
and actually it's I was like now do I
just think it sounds fake because I know
that she did it so I'm just kind of like
oh obviously fake but then I was reading
a thing where like one of the cops that
was interviewing her said yeah she would
make sobbing noises but she wasn't
crying like there was no tears so he
thought that was like super fishy there
have been cases where carjackers and
carjacked cars
and accidentally there were kids in the
back yeah I've heard of that all the
cases that I remembered
uh the the carjacker drives a couple
miles [__] Parks the car and jumps
out yes
right yeah that wasn't the whole you
just wanted it was four not right not
what he took the car for right
so yeah and it's like [__] I don't want
to get into even more trouble if I get
caught
um he doesn't want the kids at all yeah
you know what I mean right he's not
gonna [__] just throw him out of the
car so they just [__] park the car
and run and then they can try to carjack
another car yeah
Oracle says the funny thing about Susan
Smith saying it was a black man they had
her work with a forensic artist yeah
that's right uh too and the forensic
artist was super suspicious of her too
which we'll get into a little bit
um just draw a picture of the suspect
the suspect looked a lot like her
husband with some Afro-American features
well one of the things that kind of
tipped the cops off to the beginning was
that the forensic artist said that you
know the description she gave of the
dude was like super vague yeah it was
basically like oh it was a tall black
man with like a plaid coat on and stuff
like that and even the forensic artist
was just like this like somebody that's
actually been carjacked and this woman
that had did the forensic artist drawing
she's like you know I've worked with
hundreds of people
and she's like and this was not she's
like most people if you've been
carjacked you look the dude right in the
face or a lot more specific they're like
but she was super vague but then really
specific about some details that didn't
like work out all that good so like I
said even though
um you know people kind of went along
with it and the cops were like yeah we
had to follow up on that lead because
cause you know we don't know we didn't
have the evidence to say no she was back
but they were suspicious of her pretty
much from like day two of the investor
like that from the day after she said
that she was carjacked like they knew
something was not right like just the
way she was acting and they give her lie
detector tests and all that other kind
of stuff so you know what I mean uh
James homie Holmes says first time
hearing about these women oh [__] what
you must be very young or not from the
US I mean these were hugely hugely this
was a while back I mean the Susan Smith
case was 1994 and the Andrea Yates case
was 2001.
so um but at the time this was
everywhere this was all over yeah Smith
just wanted a new husband wouldn't that
what it was she wanted a new family well
kinda she had like yeah we'll get into
it we'll get into that in a little while
and like I said it's I found it
fascinating too because these women
their personalities are kind of similar
I mean there's a lot of differences too
which I'll get into a bit but just from
a psychological standpoint
um they had a lot of very similar
attributes which I found was very
interesting
um but yeah James says uh some women
shouldn't be parents holy [__] uh some
people goes for both sexes yeah I mean
some people should absolutely not have
children
um yeah James said was born in 97. I'm
familiar with a lot of True Crime but
not this in particular oh okay so you
are so you are younger uh thank you very
much Jeffy art today we had families on
campus and some of them had very loud
and fussy children I thought about your
show during the origins sure I guess
felt that
I mean yeah that's a well I mean you
know we've all been there
but uh but yeah all right so let's talk
about Susan Smith first now as I said
back in 1984 this happened in a dinky
little town called Union South Carolina
and
um so basically most people kind of know
the outline of the story what ended up
happening was that Susan Smith she was
um separated from her husband David at
this juncture they were still kind of on
again off again
um but they had two sons Michael who was
three
and Alexander who was 14 months old
now she
claimed and we'll get into what really
happened later on but she claimed at
first that as I mentioned a black man
had approached her car uh and got into
the car at gunpoint and told her to
drive or and then like told her to get
out of the car or whatever like told her
to get out of the car and then took off
and she didn't know like where they went
to
and she even like ran to the to a
neighbor's house and like called the
cops and she was freaking out and
everything like that so after that like
everybody obviously thought oh my God
her kids have been kidnapped and it was
just like a whole big National thing
where everybody she was all over the
news she was like crying and begging for
the kids to come back and so was David
like I said they were separated but they
were still um you know co-parenting the
kids like and they seemed to still like
I said they were still [__] like
every now and then she was [__] a
bunch of other people too well so was he
but um
that the relationship the family
Dynamics in both of these cases are
astounding let me just say that so it
was an on-again off-again relationship
it was a I mean no they were married you
were married but um I mean they married
very young I believe she was only 19.
um and she was already pregnant when
they got married and
um
basically they were just very volatile
uh they both seemed very very immature
yeah they they were constantly cheating
on one another like breaking up and
getting back together that kind of [__]
yeah look 19 that's Young by today's
standard that was not Young by the south
standards of the of that time I knew a
lot of people that were married by them
but still I mean she just seemed like a
very immature yeah and they were like
that
the ones that the ones that I knew that
got married at that age in the South
were like that too they're wild just
because they were married didn't mean
that they were like normal well yeah I
mean Susan Smith big child over wild she
was well the thing about her too and
this was kind of similar to what Andrea
Yates was like not quite Susan Smith
seemed like one of those women
or girls when they're younger who they
don't feel
um they're very emotionally needy
um they don't feel like they got enough
love or affection uh from their families
and so these particular types of girls
will seek it out just by like [__] a
bunch of men because they think that
that's love and that's they're trying to
get love from all these dudes so they
just become very promiscuous and um
Susan Smith seems to fit that to a t
um at the time that she killed her
children I believe she was having sex
with four different men one of them her
stepfather but we'll get into that in a
little bit too I mean he actually to be
fair
um he actually started molesting her
when she was a teenager
and their relationship continued into
until she was in her 20s at which point
she said oh it was consensual but I'm
like I don't know man there's something
really [__] weird about that oh yeah
that's [__] weird
so yeah we'll get into that like I said
the [__] family Dynamics in both
these cases are horrific ages they're
just like horrifying like you said
though there are some people are just
like that yeah just something about the
environment they come from might be
genetics too I don't know it could be it
could be your early family just family
or
they're in a weird place there's a lot
of poverty and stuff you know
yeah and this seems like like I said
this is a very small town Oracle points
out premarital sex is also cheap
entertainment especially in a small town
yeah yep yeah yeah which is probably why
that's why you see like so much free
internet yeah this was 1994. I mean [__]
Mississippi was wild man
rural Mississippi would think that you
know like okay Outsiders
New York and California have this had
this weird view that the South was
puritanical no The South was [__]
Wild
um yeah there's religion and [__] but
that didn't stop him from [__]
[__] doing crazy [__] man the dude
that had the most girlfriends in the
town would have been the preacher
you know just
it probably the most perverse one but uh
no it's just uh Mississippi was pretty
wild like that although they wasn't
always negative like this though you
know I mean there was a lot of positive
aspects to it but in this particular
case
this is some freaky [__] yeah like I
said I don't generally have a problem
with promiscuity as long as everybody's
consenting and safe
um you know and as long as you're not
like [__] young and it's like a
[__] you know what I mean like the
age differential but it's like you know
what I mean I don't really have a
problem with that but this just seemed
she seemed to be doing it to like
I don't know like fill a need in her
life that she wasn't being met from her
family like it was that because I knew
some people like that growing up they're
just kind of like Oh Daddy didn't love
well I was gonna say daddy didn't love
me but it's kind of [__] up what
happened to her family her daddy loved
her but he
blew himself away yeah when she was six
well um so he committed suicide yeah
well you know um
the male female relationship you know at
its core is kind of transactional and if
you're
low lower income and you're a pretty
girl and you're young
that's probably the only thing you got
going for you in an early age you can
find out that you can move up in life if
you have a bunch of boyfriends now she
the interesting thing about Susan Smith
though is that for the small town
um she was actually kind of more on that
her family wasn't wealthy but she was
like more on the upper upper end
um and in fact that was kind of one of
the one of the um objections that her
family had to her marrying David because
they thought he was like beneath her
because he was from like the wrong side
is that that mating style is in all
classes they got rich hoes too girls
that grew up with silver spoons in their
mouths so I can horse riding lessons and
everything and go to universities she's
got an MRS degree and she just [__]
Rich dudes
you know
that's how she moves up it's the same
thing
it happens in every class so just
because she was on the upper end of the
lower class doesn't
you know
stop that effect you know they're out
there Oracle says hey we had internet
back then well in Charleston and it was
dial up yeah yeah I think we did have I
can't remember when we first got dialed
might have been 94 or 95. around this
time I remember uh internet was starting
to appear I was Gulf Coast of
Mississippi after after the army with my
first wife and I was amazed that you
could order you could order clothes off
of the internet and get them delivered
to your house using an ATM card
like something out of dam Arnold
Schwarzenegger movie it was like
something out of [__] Running Man
I was amazed you didn't need them all
yeah and I said those malls are going to
vanish what do you need them all for I
called it
High Desert zero zero four said um all
these small towns are full of mess
yeah they are actually I don't think I
don't know about 94 that might have been
pretty the mess but now nowadays for
sure yeah population control
uh slasher Fred said there was a movie
called Freedom land which is centered
around the Susan Smith murder case I
don't think I've ever seen that actually
I watched like a bunch of documentaries
about her there was there was a really
good one from a few years back that um
had like Bill Curtis on it he's always
good I like his voice or whatever but uh
but yeah so but I didn't watch the movie
I've never done meth it must be a hell
of a drug they'll do it do their teeth
fall out
yeah I just really have no desire yeah I
don't like any I don't like any
amphetamines like I don't either I don't
remember to keep me up from I don't I
don't need that [__] what do you want
that for yeah that's what I mean the
really the only the only drugs I'm an
advocate for like personally is like
hallucinogens like those are fun but
other than that no thanks I don't want
anything that like speeds me out I don't
want anything that makes me [__]
paranoid or Spazzy or anything like that
no thank you I don't need that smoked
opium in Egypt that was great
[__] that like chills me out you know
what I mean like chills me out or makes
me more creative or something like that
I don't I don't really need something
that's going to like make me all I don't
need anything like that yeah you sleep
it off and you wake up the next morning
you sleep it off and it doesn't even
call you back it's not addictive I mean
you'd probably have to smoke a lot of it
to get addicted to it but you know you
should be like cigarettes or alcohol
that could happen to alcohol
you know James said no hard drugs only
cannabis and psychedelics for me thank
you yeah I'm kind of on the same page
I'm not a big weed person I don't like
weed because it makes me even more
paranoid than usual
um but psychedelics uh yeah I'm I'm down
with that but other than that weed makes
you feel vulnerable
I feel like I would be able to fight if
somebody attacked me
I don't feel like that but it does make
me feel like even more self-conscious
and paranoid like everyone's looking at
me I'd be able to fight on acid
yeah you probably oh yeah it's like oh
he's gonna drive he's all wavy I can
even drive well on it never hear him as
long as his dose isn't too high
desert said I remember after the Andrea
Yates case people were going to that
Lake and take I guess you mean the Susan
Smith one because Andrea Yates draft her
kids in a bathtub Susan Smith was the
one with the lake uh people were going
to that Lake and taking photos of
themselves there it was weird yeah and
you know what's [__] up about that is
that
later on like there was a van of people
that had gone to that boat ramp they
tore the boat ramp out now it's not
there anymore but they went to that boat
ramp to take pictures because like oh
this is a place where it happened and
that car slid off into the thing and
like a bunch of people drowned like
including a bunch of kids
James brings up a good uh angle poverty
also plays hell on your genes it does
yeah because well there's a brain
there's a brain drain effect
anybody who's got
higher IQ gets the [__] out of there
leaving behind a gene pool of just
people who are dumb well the thing about
it too is that poverty poverty if you
are raised in poverty
um there are a lot of environmental
factors that will affect your yeah whole
entire life later on you know if you
have like bad nutrition when you're
younger like that like everything like
that yeah like you know you don't get
the health care that you need because
there's no money and a lot of it's
mental stimulation they don't get proper
mental stimulation that too so it's like
it affects your whole entire life like I
think people forgot they're raised by
they're raised by [__] family members
that have like [__] an 80 word
vocabulary if that so you know their
their speech skills are terrible
yeah it's just sad all around because
they didn't ask to be born into that you
know what I mean it's like
it's not their fault but
that's it's just [__] up that happens
but that happens too so okay
so Susan Smith I found out this is very
interesting well it was interesting to
me because Susan Smith was born exactly
one year before I was she was born on my
birthday September 26 1971 I was
actually born September 26 1972.
so she was actually born in Union South
Carolina lived there her whole entire
life
um you know like I said very very small
town oh yeah you're older than her
basically yeah
um and she was she had um two older
brothers
now when she was six years old her dad
who she was uh very close to and looked
up to and stuff like that
um committed suicide he actually took a
shotgun and put it in his midsection and
shot and he didn't die right away
um but it killed him later on
prior to that
um I think he had been like an okay dude
but then uh he kind of fell into
alcoholism depression uh things of that
nature and kind of became violent
um toward her mother things of that sort
uh Susan actually tried to commit
suicide herself when she was 13 years
old
uh and it wouldn't be the first time
either so it was just like kind of a
messed up situation all around like the
family dynamic
so then her mom whose name is Linda
married her stepdad whose name is
Beverly Russell
now this guy
um he was divorced but he had three kids
from the previous marriage
and he was actually fairly wealthy he
was a stockbroker
um he was the he was kind of a high up
muckety muck in like the South Carolina
Republican party also a big high
matrimuk in the Christian coalition
so they moved to like a much nicer house
like in this real exclusive part of the
town and blah blah however when Susan
was 15 years old her stepfather started
molesting her like he started groping
her and things like that
now Susan actually did inform uh the
guidance counselor at her school about
this when she was 16 years old said hey
you know my stepdad is molesting me
um and told her mom as well
now her mom actually you know to her
credit she actually did go to the do and
be like what the [__] like you know what
I mean like she actually did confront
him about it
um and he said oh I'm sorry and I
promise I'll never do it again I'll go
to family therapy or whatever you want
or anything like that
um which they did that but he kept doing
it anyway yeah so you know what I mean
um
he sounds great uh for I mean okay I
will say that later on after Susan
killed her kids and you know and there
was trial and everything he did actually
get on the stand at the trial and take
responsibility partial responsibility
for the murder because of what he had
done to her like he did admit it and he
did so I was like at least he did that
he shouldn't done to start with but at
least he was man enough to come out and
go yeah I did this [__] and I feel
partially responsible for what she did
because I [__] her up yeah credit to
the guy but I don't think he had
anything to do with it well I yeah I
don't know a lot of girls have been
through some [__] like that they don't
kill their kids that's what I'm saying
it's just kind of like and I'm always
kind of like I don't
I don't know and we I think we talked
about this before when we were talking
about the Long Island serial killer or
when we were talking about other serial
killer cases we always kind of go to
their background because I think it's
interesting because I think it does
give some insight into maybe why they
did [__] they did later on but it's like
it's never going to be the complete
answer because obviously like some
people have had just like horrific
[__] childhoods and then they grew up
and they were fine yeah you know what I
mean or they got their [__] together
that like they didn't kill anybody I
don't want to speak too soon and jump to
the conclusion but it's always been my
opinion based on this case I mean
Jenny's refreshing my mind right now but
I remembered how I felt about this woman
back then and I just considered I just
thought she was just real self-centered
and real selfish
yeah I got that impression too like she
was kind of like a narcissist she was
very attention seeking yeah
she I mean she did have some problems uh
she had uh you know she had some mental
problems but um but yeah she did really
seem I think she knew what she was doing
and
um
even after she did it I just got the
feeling that she didn't really care all
that much maybe that's I was I I recall
thinking that she was basically just
trying to move up in life and she was
monkey branching from one guy to the
next and she was crowdsourcing men's
help to get ahead and she was trying to
get rid of the old husband get a new one
in a new family this is the kids were
just an obstacle to her
having more fun really and getting more
wealth I just I just thought and more
notoriety and attention and [__] yeah
because I will note that I believe it
was like five or six days before the
murder
um some of her co-workers did say that
she'd said said something like I wonder
what my life would have been like if I
hadn't married and had kids so yeah yeah
now granted you know that the stepdad
was messing with her
um which he shouldn't have been doing
should have been doing that but probably
that didn't make her kill the kids no uh
but maybe what that did is just
reinforcing her mind at an early age
that she could get what she wanted from
guys I think that's me yeah maybe so
Supply her feminine ways and get men to
[__] help her and [__] help move
her along in life and she was going to
do that to as many men as she could
get her hands on
um and if the kids were in the way it
obviously proof's in the pudding she'd
eliminate her own children to get what
she wanted so that's evil I don't care
how you that's that's evil that's what
that is yeah
yeah I agree with you that's evil I
agree with you
like I said when we talk about angry
Yates I actually do feel bad for her but
um Susan Smith not so much
like I said that [__] shouldn't happen
to her when she was a kid that sucks
that her dad killed himself and you know
there was all kind of other and she got
molested and all that other kind of
stuff but it's like it doesn't
I think she did what she did like you
said for selfish reasons yeah yeah she
worked in she probably [__]
rationalized that [__] well it's like
abortion It's Just Happening later it's
like that maybe that's very late term
maybe that's what she is maybe that's
how she's on they're not real people
[__] is crazy Jeff here that I think
season Smith just felt bad that she got
caught yeah yeah I kind of think so too
yeah okay
psycho
so uh so yeah
so later on um while she was still in
high school like I said after she'd you
know told them about the molestation and
everything like that uh she made a
second suicide attempt uh like I said
her first one was uh when she was 13.
now around this time period the thing
about Susan Smith and the same is true
of Andrea Yates both of them I don't
know if I'd call Susan Smith an
overachiever but she was
um she was a really really good student
like she was in a bunch of clubs and
it's like she was voted friendliest
female like in the friendliest female
that sounds so [__] clinical
um in the yearbook and all this other
kind of stuff so both of these women
when they were teenagers were very very
high achieving which I thought was
interesting I'll get into a little bit
more with Andrea Yates because I think
it was more pronounced in her case but
the same was true like like I said Susan
Smith was like a really good student and
all this other kind of stuff even though
all the stuff was going on at home and
she was like super normal like I don't
think anybody would have imagined that
she would have done something this
[__] horrible but you know
so she actually
um when she was a little bit older like
18 19. she had a part-time job at the
good old Winn-Dixie
uh Supermarket which it's I don't think
they have those all over the country
that's like this other thing yeah
they're nice nice now well they're nice
now they used to be shitholes but yeah
we had to up their game they well yeah
because Publix was kicking their ass
yeah so but I remember when I was a kid
like public was the nice fancy place
that we couldn't afford to go so we had
to go to like Win Dixie or Goodings
about Piggly Wiggly or Piggly Wiggly
yeah and those were like um not as nice
they were a [__] budget yeah yeah
they were out it's nice
um I'm Gonna Win Dixie now they got a
good Deli and salad bar and yeah now
they're all fancy well like I said they
had to compete yeah like they couldn't
be like [__] crab legs
yeah that's why we always got one yeah
[Laughter]
so yeah so she worked at the Winn-Dixie
and um while she was at the Winn-Dixie
she was also uh having an affair with an
older married co-worker at the
Winn-Dixie like I told you yeah well
yeah like I said she was just like
running through the dudes
um and he broke up with her
and she
um this is when she made her uh suicide
attempt she tried to uh overdo
um so she actually uh got
sent to a psychiatrist would he make
some kind of promise to her or something
um what do you mean
she tried to kill herself because he
broke up with her because he broke up
with her what do you promise to marry
her or something well the thing about
Susan Smith that you see this again and
again
um including the relationship that you
know ostensibly led to the killing of
her children
she just seemed very needy I think that
she just wanted these dudes to like
love her forever and just I think she
had like a really immature
idea of how relationships were supposed
to be
you know what I mean yeah she just
really every time she was in a
relationship with a dude just like this
is the one you know what I mean and then
more than one attack I know but then
well I think she was like looking for
that and like then when it didn't work
out she had like this big like I said
which is a very teenage thing to do she
was crowdsourcing yeah crowdsourcing her
men
she's in case one fell through she'd had
backups
yeah and like I said she really did seem
to and maybe it was because her dad uh
committed suicide when he when she was
little
um she's gonna lose the man she was yeah
I think she was just constantly like
looking for like a father figure or just
a male figure in her life and if you
know what I mean she needed more than
one like you said because she don't want
to if she lost one then there would be
another one there yeah waiting in the
wings she didn't really seem to have
trouble getting men
um and actually some of the dudes like
spoke quite um favorably of her
but
she um was clearly very immature I mean
she's very young at this stage she's
probably only 18 or 19 at this point but
yeah so she had attempted suicide again
after this older who guy who she was
having an affair with he was married
um you know how old was he you know uh I
don't know actually I don't know I think
he's 20s 30s or something like that so I
mean she was like I said she was young
she was only 18 or 19. it's not like he
was in his 50s or six I don't think so
right I don't think he was that old he
was just like older than her yeah if I
remember correctly
um also she's basically like
so she when she goes to a psychologist
psychiatrist
she tells because remember how I said
like the stepdad had started molesting
her when she was 15.
and then but she told the psychiatrist
now she was 19 or 20 or however old she
was that now she was still having sex
with him but now it was consensual she
told the psychiatrist is that she didn't
want her mom getting all the men's
attention and so she was asleep I don't
know how that I don't know what the
dynamic between her and her stepfather
was
um because that's just all kind of
[__] up so I don't know if that's just
what she told herself or if she really
believed that or I don't really know
like I said it's not right like she
wasn't right completely like she had
some weird ideas about [__] she's
probably telling the truth but maybe so
yeah maybe they're not blood relatives
and it's he's fitting the bill for what
she's looking for a father type figure
an older guy to take care of her how old
was he 30s
who are stepfather yeah um
yeah he might have been mid to late 30s
yeah at that time or maybe 40s I can't
yeah and also it's kind of like maybe
rivalry against her mom well yeah she
basically said as much yeah she yeah
she's proven to herself that she's worth
more than her mom more power than her
yeah like I said it's messed up like the
whole thing is yes you have uh uh some
weird Dynamics there
narcissism yeah I definitely got that
impression yeah James says she wanted a
relationship she could control and the
dudes just wanted a pump and dump just
my unprofessional input yeah but yeah
that's probably yeah that's probably it
so uh so yeah
now
so she works at the Winn-Dixie and then
there's also another dude who works at
the Winn-Dixie whose name is David
um and the two of them hooked up and
started dating now David he also came
from kind of a weird background
um there was also a lot of suicide in
his family
uh his brother had died an accident or
so or no he died of Crohn's Disease I
think so and he was like real real young
and he'd also been like his family was
Jehovah's Witnesses so he was like came
from like a real real strict uh
religious background so it was that kind
of thing
and David
they dated for about a year
and then they got married at this stage
I believe Susan was only 19 years old
and she was already two months pregnant
with Michael
who would be three when he died
um David at this stage was 20. uh and
like I said he had also had some tragedy
in his value I believe his father also
attempted suicide at least so there was
a lot of that going around like in these
two families which is bizarre
so
the two of them so they so they get
married and almost instantly
um they're just like constantly like I
said the relationship was very volatile
they both seemed you know young kind of
immature
and they're constantly arguing
and they're just constantly cheating on
each it wasn't just her like he did it
too
um you know he was [__] around on her
she was [__] around on him they kept
like breaking up and getting back
together and it was just this big
[__] [__] show you know what I mean
so
in 1993.
Susan started having an affair with a
dude named Tom Findlay now he was
actually the son of the guy who owned
the company that she worked for conso
products which was like one of the big
employers like in this real small town
she was a secretary there
and uh so she was
you know in her early 20s I guess she
was 21 22 around this time he was 27.
and uh they dated for a little while
um now Tom Finley
was kind of considered this very small
towns one of the big eligible bachelors
right because he was single uh he came
from a very very wealthy family one of
the wealthiest families in town wasn't
much to look at gotta say uh at least
from at least from the the brief uh
video footage I saw of him but you know
he had money and he was single and he
seemed like an okay dude you know what I
mean just from from everything that I
heard about him so uh you know she was
thinking maybe that well this is like
her ticket out of here right because
he's really rich and they did have a
relationship for a while probably I
think it lasted like less than a year
though I think it was like nine or ten
months or something like that
so in October
of 1994. Tom Findlay sends her a letter
that kind of looked like a [__] I've
read the whole thing it kind of looked
like a form letter which is kind of
[__] up
but apparently she was super super in
love with him and he really liked her
too like a lot of the letter he was kind
of you could tell that he was trying to
like let her down easy like he's like
you know I think you're awesome and
you're like an awesome person and it's
like you know she had gone back to
school and was working and he's like
yeah he's still doing that and I'm so
proud of you and all this other kind of
stuff but basically he said
um you know you
kind of want this to be like the big
relationship like oh it's you and me
together forever and he's like and
that's you know maybe you'll find that
but it's not going to be with me and he
basically straight up told her basically
the one thing that he didn't like about
her was her kids
um he and he said that like pretty but
he didn't word it exactly like that but
almost like the way he said it was um
you know the one thing I'm talking about
that you know doesn't suit me is your
children he's like I'm sure that they're
good children but they could be the best
children in the world the fact remains
that I just don't want children
um so that's basically what he said so
he's like so we can't see each other
anymore he's like you know he just
didn't want a ready-made family is
basically what he said to her so like I
said a little harsh but dude should have
said anything I well I I don't know if
that necessarily would have worked
either but because she then she would
have just kept
like carrying on but so he sends her
this last year I don't like you anymore
yeah I mean maybe he shouldn't have even
said that yeah I don't really like you
anymore
I gotta I gotta go that kind of [__]
yeah
James said uh bro ain't no way that
seriously could have push her to do what
she did yeah yeah I mean I I don't know
like I I don't know if he hadn't said
that like you said maybe if he had just
sent her like a mean letter and said hey
I don't like you anymore piss off yeah
um women react to that a lot better
maybe [__] you then that's what I mean
maybe she would if she was gonna oh well
go [__] yourself and then just go and
find another well she was still married
at the time but well I mean she was
separated from from uh David at this
point because that like I said they were
constantly separating and getting back
together
um so the fact but the fact that he said
that like I said I read the letter that
he sent and the fact that he kind of
tried to sugarcoat it because he was
trying to be nice to her and like let
her down easy
because I guess he did like her
um but the fact that he just said it
real baldly like that I'm not blaming it
I'm not saying that but I you know I
don't know would she have done it anyway
if he hadn't said that I don't really
know you know what I mean I don't know
but regardless
um he did say that in the letter
so on uh when she got the letter
um basically she um later on the same
day she got into a fight with David
um because David had like gone through
her [__] like he knew that she was
always like [__] around and he was
always trying to look because even
though he was [__] around too he
always seemed like really jealous about
it like what like what are you seeing
that dude for what are you doing and I'm
like dude you're [__] around too so
what the hell
um but yeah David was no prize either
gonna say I mean but he seems like
okay now like he's got his life together
and whatever but I don't know he didn't
seem like that great of a person either
but I mean he's not really to blame in
this situation gonna say
but
um he went through her [__] and I guess
he found the letter from Tom Finley
and they had a big fight about it and I
think too now I don't know if this is
true or not or I don't know if Susan
just said this to Tom Findlay like to
make Tom Finley feel bad
for some reason but she also told Tom
that she was [__] his dad who was the
owner of the the business that she
worked for you know what I mean was it
true I don't know okay that's what I
mean I don't know if she just said that
like to get back at him yeah or if she
was actually [__] that the old dude
damn I don't know I don't know if she
was I mean it's it's for perfectly
possible yeah because she was [__]
her stepfather yeah and her husband
and this Tom Finley dude it's bigger and
bigger and bigger that's what I mean
this is wholeflation the hoe is inflated
yeah that's pretty she becomes a bigger
and bigger hoe the more you find up it's
just [__] hilarious
I mean it's like it's [__] crazy I
mean it's [__] crazy
so so I don't know if she was also
[__] Tom Finley's dad who was the
owner of of the company that she
searched for yeah it wouldn't surprise
me yeah but it also wouldn't surprise me
if she just told him that like to piss
him off or something equally plausible
that is equally plausible so I don't
actually know if the two of them were
[__] or not but she did say that now
I don't know if her husband heard that
rumor and got mad about that too but
like so she got this letter
and then on top of it like her and David
had this big huge fight
um and then like after she went back to
Tom Finley and was like uh you know said
hey I'm [__] your dad and then he was
like get the [__] out of my face you
know what I mean
and then so a few hours after that so
after that whole argument what ended up
happening
she ends up like she goes and picks up
her kids from daycare like she normally
would straps him in the back of the car
like she normally would and then she is
so upset by this letter that she's got
and this fight that she's had with David
that she just kind of like drives
aimlessly around like she goes to this
one bar Wolf the bar uh there was only
one bar in this town that's how small
this town is they have one bar
um and what the [__] was it called
something nuts something nuts Hickory
nuts that's what's the name of it
um but yeah it's just like this Tavern
and Restaurant or whatever so she goes
there and like she sits in the parking
lot and she was like talking to a friend
of hers and this friend of hers was also
a co-worker and she kept asking about is
top you know did you guys go to dinner
with Tom Finley did he ask about me and
they're like no he didn't say anything
about you and then like she got like
really upset about that then she went
back to her workplace and like tried to
talk to Tom again and he's like look you
can't be here uh you know I feel bad how
[__] worked out but you can't just like
keep coming back here it's like it looks
bad so she was like really trying to
like [__]
get back in with this dude and it was
like really upsetting here right
so after a couple of hours of driving
around in the car with the kids in the
back
she evidently went to the uh boat ramp
on John D long Lake
and
let the car roll into the lake with her
kids in the back
now later on she would say that
um initially she had planned to commit
suicide which is not crazy because she
actually had attempted it a few times
before
um so she was basically saying well I
was gonna you know go into the lake with
the kids but then like at the last
minute she was like she got out the car
but then she reached back into the car
and took off the emergency brake and let
the car roll into the lake
how old were the kids the kids are like
under two or three three one of them was
three and one of them was 14 months and
they were both in car seat the
three-year-old would have kind of known
what the hell was going on
which yeah it's it's [__] horrifying
yeah it's horrifying
so yeah so she puts him in her car which
is like I said a monster Protege and
lets it roll into the lake
and then she runs to a nearby house
and ask them to call the police
because a black man has carjacked her
and has abducted her children
now obviously everybody at first kind of
believed this story her husband believed
it everybody believed it
and everybody felt really really bad for
her you know as you would
so she goes on TV her and David are on
TV her whole family are on there like
begging this Phantom carjacker to please
bring the children back without harming
them she's on there like pretending to
cry
um you know what I mean like I said it's
very clear and I don't know if it's just
because I know that she really killed
them but like seeing the footage from
before anybody else knew that
um it's very clear that she's
fake crying like just the way that she's
talked like she's really
overselling it I'm gonna say like yeah
you'd be upset in that Stitch if that
legitimately did happen you'd be really
upset about it but just the way she was
going on about it just seemed really
fakey
and the cops thought so as well
pretty much the second day of the
investigation and one of the cops like I
was watching an interview with him and
he said look you know you have to
kind of explore every single lead so we
were looking for this guy and there
actually was a time when like they did
find a car that looked kind of like her
car it was a monster Protege that had
like a little kid in the back that was
kind of fit the description
um you know so they were like
investigating that but it turned out not
to be him obviously because that kid was
already dead
so they did explore that Avenue however
the cops pretty much from the day after
the murder or The Disappearance at that
point
some of the cops were pretty [__]
suspicious of Susan Smith
for several reasons one of the reasons
was that one um you know her reactions
to things seemed very faky
she always seemed like when they were
taking her places because she was like
all over the media and everything like
that when they were taking her places
she seemed more concerned about whether
Tom was going to come see her or call
her than she was about finding her kids
like they thought that was a little
weird
um and sometimes she would ask something
like was I on TV did I look good on TV
or something like that she would ask
questions like that
also
um they gave her a series of lie
detector tests they gave David one too
because you know usually a lot of times
like when when children die um you know
I don't know what the percentage is but
it's quite a high percentage It's
usually the parents the parents are
involved
so um so they were the first ones they
kind of looked at so they gave David a
lie detector test and it was very clear
he passed it with flying colors it was
very clear he knew nothing about uh
where the children were or what had
happened he did believe Susan Smith
though he said he believed her
wholeheartedly had no reason not to
however when they gave Susan Smith the
lie detector test
um several times the results were always
inconclusive and they said that she
always in particular tripped up on one
specific question which was do you know
where the children are
like she would always say no and it
always indicated deception at that point
I believe she took nine
uh lie detector tests over the course of
the days she took one like every day or
something like that and she always
tripped up on that one particular
question so that was a little bit fishy
another thing too is that the story that
she initially told to the cops that she
was upset about getting this letter from
her boyfriend to like essentially
breaking up with her and so she's like
so I was like well I'm I'm gonna drive
over here and she's like I was gonna
drive to this friend's house and then
they found out that friend wasn't even
home and wasn't even expecting her to
come over so what the hell was that all
about and then she said oh and I'm I
went to Walmart and did some shopping
nobody that worked at Walmart that night
remembered her and the kids being in
there also one of the things that really
like raised some alarm Bells was that
she said when she was when this Phantom
black man had carjacked her
she said she was stopped at a stoplight
at this particular intersection and that
there were no other cars around hence no
Witnesses
and the cop was like at that particular
intersection
the light that she would have been
stopped at it's like that light is
always green unless cars are coming the
other way like to trigger the the sensor
pad so there's like so there's no way if
there were no other cars around that she
would have been stopped at a red light
because it would have been green if
there were no other cars so they thought
that was a little bit weird also the
forensic science the forensic artist
again like said that the description
that she gave this dude was very very
vague
so they did like investigate that thing
but they were like investigating Susan
as well and one cop in particular like
one of the kind of lead investigator on
the thing he was so convinced that Susan
knew what was going on he's like he's
like At first I didn't think she'd
killed them
it's like what we thought was going on
was that she was afraid that like if her
and David got divorced that he would get
custody so she hid them somewhere he's
like that's kind of what we were
thinking we didn't think that she killed
them initially but then like as time
went on they were like oh yeah maybe she
didn't do something but that was the
first thing that they were thinking that
she there was like yeah that it was like
a custody battle that she had like hid
him from him and said oh they got
kidnapped because that has happened
before that's the more common root thing
right right so it's very rare that a
woman kills her own kids
it is it is very rare it is very rare
um but I was I listened to something the
other day that said a thousand kids in
the US every year killed by their
parents not necessarily their moms it
could be their dads too
yeah
um well it's not but that's not no it's
usually like dudes they're on all kinds
of drugs they're not feeding the kid the
little kid's real small too small to
protect itself enraged dad just out of
his mind on some kind of damn meth kills
a kid by shaking it to death that kind
of [__]
yeah
it's not usually not as cold-blooded
it's usually just they go psycho yeah
something you know fighting they're
fighting each other and they turn they
turn on the kid
drugs involved low IQs involved that too
yeah
so
um so yeah
so for nine days uh this woman was on
national TV
on all the news programs all the morning
programs all that kind of stuff pleading
for the safe return of her two children
when she knew God damn well that they
were dead
now that she kept the thing another
thing they thought was weird is that
when they started sort of like low-key
insinuating that she had something to do
with it they're like her whole demeanor
changed like she got like super
belligerent
um I can't believe that you'd think that
I do something like that like she would
get like that which she wasn't like
before they said she was usually like
pretty calm and pretty passive and stuff
but she would just absolutely get super
defensive like whenever somebody
suggested something like that so they
thought that was a little fishy as well
one of the cops decided he was gonna do
like some kind of psychology honor and
he actually told her and this you can do
this he actually told her a little bit
of a fib
he said that they that him he that he
had some undercover drug uh officers or
whatever like um what do you call him
undercover offices yeah like working at
that particular intersection like where
she said the carjacking occurred
um and he's like and he said and they
didn't see anything like that was not
true but at this point he was pretty
sure that her story because all these
little inconsistent details like every
time she said something like it didn't
really add up so he knew that she knew
more than she was letting on so he's
like so I decided that I was going to
tell her all of this kind of little fib
and stuff just to see if I could get her
to confess and like wear her down after
a while because she had to pull out more
lies yeah that yeah that's what I mean
so he was kind of like trying to work on
her because they said that you know for
nine days she absolutely like absolutely
insisted that she didn't have anything
to do with this I can't believe you
would even insinuate such a thing
um blah blah and she kind of like had
everybody fooled but finally after nine
days
um one of the cops like took her in this
room like in this church or whatever and
finally
um he was able to persuade her gently
into confessing and she basically said
the first thing she said she said she
started to cry and then she said the
kids are not all right that was the
first thing she said
and then they got everybody in there and
they got her to write down uh her
confession and it's crazy looking at her
confession because I looked at the one
like a you know a photocopy of the one
that she wrote like she just wrote it by
hand and she has she has very teenagery
handwriting like even in every time she
wants to use the word heart she just
draws a little heart it's just very it
looks like a teenager's handwriting like
in their Journal
so basically she said her story was that
she you know after she got the letter
from the boyfriend she was suicidal
and then she started thinking well I
don't want my kids to grow up without a
mom so we're all gonna go out together
that was what she thought
so she drove around for a couple of
hours thinking about this and then she
drives to the boat ramp where she said I
don't think she'd ever been there before
and she said that she was still in the
car and released the break and let it
roll forward but then stopped it then
let it roll forward and stop it like she
was gonna go in there too but then in
the end she got out left the babies in
there and then reached in the window and
took the emergency brake off and just
stood there and kind of watched while
the car went into the thing and this is
[__] up I didn't see the whole thing
because I know I'm not I don't want that
rattling around in my head but at the
trial they actually did a reenactment
with the same kind of car and at the
same place
so they wanted to demonstrate how long
it would have taken for the car to sink
a long time
um five minutes and 52 seconds say float
yeah well and the thing about it because
even from the beginning of the
investigation when when they were still
going with the carjacking story like
before she confessed
they still had the you know the cops
still had enough wherewithal to have
divers search that Lake
problem was
they were thinking that somebody had
driven into the lake like at high speed
so they were thinking that the car was
going to be like right there like near
the shore so they only went out to like
120 feet
turned out that the car and here's the
creepy thing too is that when Susan
Smith like confessed and they're like
okay well to know that this confession
is legit like where is the car like
where are the children she told him
exactly where it was like they sent the
divers out there and they found it it
was like 18 feet down or some [__] like
that like in the bottom of the lake and
the lake was like real murky they hadn't
seen it before because they hadn't gone
out far enough because like I said they
were thinking that somebody at high
speed had driven into the lake which in
the car would have been right there but
the thing about it was she just let it
roll into there which meant the car
floated for a while and then went face
down and it actually flipped over when
they found the car it was upside down so
the kids were hanging yeah from and they
said you could see them through the
window like when they found the car
which is must have been creepy as how
long they've been down there nine days
yeah they were starting to rot
Wells were getting them probably well um
the car was it was all closed but I mean
it was full of water obviously but
um but yeah the window was open
now
the windows were the windows were all
closed oh okay she didn't after you said
she reached into the window and hit and
hit the uh
well that's what I heard but then I
heard that when they found the car like
the windows were on she must have uh
hit the emergency brake and slam the
door maybe yeah I guess that's what it
was and the weather was rather than
reaching in the winter because I think
all the windows were closed but so the
creepy thing to me when they did the
reenactment it would have taken some
time well because they were they were
trying to show like look you had almost
six minutes where you could have stopped
it where you could have jumped in there
and saved them you know but right well
that's what they were trying to
demonstrate that it's like you had all
this time you got someone out there I
got right because the car like didn't
sink for a really long time and the
[__] up thing is that they had um they
had a camera outside the car like when
they did the reenactment and then they
put a camera inside the car too like
where the kids would have been sitting
there's an air bubbling so yeah so
they're like so the car sank but it's
like it took a lot longer like for the
car to fill up on the inside yeah so
those kids would have been in there just
like [__] screaming their [__]
heads off yeah like not you know what I
mean upside down upside down because the
car flipped over in the car seat yeah
like I said yeah with the water coming
in which I must have been [__]
horrifying I can't I when I pictured
that when I thought of that I was like
oh my God that has been like [__]
horrible it's horrible
but yeah so
how to put that [__] in a car and foot
and throw it right there that's what I
mean oh well I don't believe from one
minute that she was gonna kill herself
um yeah apparently like well the thing
about it is that she might have crossed
her mind but then she went nah I can
just kill these kids
and went out there and did that I'll
just say somebody else did
I mean the thing about it though is that
what did she think was gonna happen
exactly not intelligent I mean not an
intelligent I mean she must have known
that she was gonna get caught at some
point yeah she's just not an intelligent
person unless she really thought
everybody was gonna buy that car tracker
story forever
I still think this whole thing about
well yeah I'm gonna kill myself and
um these uh these kids they can't be
without a mom right there that's that
[__] up mentality I don't really
believe that she thought that but if she
did which I think is unlikely that's the
same mentality the guy loses his job so
he wipes out his whole family because he
can't take care of him yeah and it was
on right and that's like something that
um that I saw somebody point out that
it's just like you know family
annihilators we've done a couple shows
about a couple of those they're usually
men yeah but um I mean this woman is
kind it's kind of the same
a similar kind of yeah kind of control
freak that he cannot
accept the fact that he's failing he
doesn't want his family to realize that
he's failing that he can't pay the bills
and what's funny is that the family
annihilators
were so traditional that they couldn't
he couldn't go to the family because
look uh I'm fired everybody's got to go
get work now to help pay the mortgage
they couldn't do that he'd rather kill
you
and then skirk away yeah under a new
identity killing his own kids to save
them from uh from the shame the shame
that's a control freak right there
that's a fire control freak well and
that's also very narcissist yeah super
narcissist because you're taking away
like your your wife and your children
yeah choice and the one guy I'm thinking
about he had a [__]
a son and a daughter and a daughter was
gorgeous and she was like in her late
teeds yeah like ready to move out
you know to move out of the house he
killed her [__] nut
well yeah and an [__] too
and it's really the this chick she's an
[__]
yeah I mean she really did come across
that way yeah so
so she goes and she was you know she
didn't get her way
with these dudes
hoflation took [__] full effect
and uh
guys didn't want to mess with her
that's no reason to kill the kids
that's [__] nuts
I mean the thing about it is that girls
just have to a lot of girls well if well
and the thing about it is that if you
really come to a place in your life
where you feel like well I don't want
these kids or I can't deal with them or
something like that it's like you know
there are other options other than
killing them obviously family members
yeah you could give them to family
members you could like put them up for
adoption which you know that's not an
ideal situation but I'm just saying it's
better than killing them most most races
most of the time
these are sometimes girls that you and I
have known over time
have had kids
they had them too young and they can
basically give them to their parents and
their parents raise them
no grandma Grandma and Grandpa baby yeah
yeah that happens a lot yeah until
she's uh in her 20s or 30s and she can
kind of [__] handle her own business
now and then you know but she sees the
kids all the time right you know
we've known girls like that yeah
I mean it happens yeah
James says family annihilators are
scarier in my opinion than serial
killers serial killers are random family
annihilators can be your [__] parents
or siblings yeah you wouldn't know they
were a family Annihilator until it was
too late you're just walking into your
room and shut the door behind you
[__] hiding behind a tour of
the [__] 22 pops you right in the
back of the head yeah that's what that
dude did with his daughter yeah popped
it right in the back of the Hill yeah
Tammy's talking about John list is that
who you're talking about I think so if
we do a show about Johnny rolls up in
the attic I thought we did and he ran
and then started a whole new family
didn't catch him until much much later
yeah Tammy said she could have let the
dad have custody exactly yeah that's
what I mean there's lots of other
options that's why I don't believe it I
believe she intended yeah I yeah I I
kind of don't know like I said she did
attempt suicide before uh so she
obviously did have problems in that
regard but
um I don't know if she really intended
to I I think she had just intended to
get them out of the way
although like I said I don't think that
she was really thinking that through
because what did she think was going to
happen oh now oh my kids are gone you
know hey hey Tom yeah let's get back
together yeah my kids are gone yeah I
don't know what happened bro right
problem solved and and for all we know
that he used the kids as an excuse to
dump her
that's what I mean they are not a band
of kids although like I said I just
didn't like her I do kind of feel like
he probably should have just told her
that I mean maybe he like I said he was
trying to let her down gently and he was
trying to be honest but I don't know if
I would have said hey the main thing I
don't like about you is your kids I
don't want kids you know what I mean so
I'm not blaming him I'm just saying that
I don't know if I would have said that
like right out right like that you know
his thinking wasn't too straight no he
thought she would take that okay
oh yeah well my kids I would never trade
my kids for this that's probably what he
thought she would no he's probably
dependent on her maternal instincts to
kick in and go [__] you [__] I
mean that's what's not what most people
would do yeah but she was obviously not
most people
so yeah so basically
um you know everybody obviously when
they thought that her kids had been
abducted uh you know were super
sympathetic and you know putting pink
ribbons and [__] all over everything not
pink ribbons that's breast cancer yellow
ribbons
but then when she confessed everybody
and actually there's a great um like
when they did the press conference like
where the investigator first came out
and said that that she's been charged
with murder you could hear a huge
audible gasp like from everybody like
because we're like you hurt everybody
gasp and I was just like that I was like
I had to listen to that a couple times
just because I don't know why I just
thought that was like really interesting
that everybody was just [__] shocked
you know what I mean
so um so everybody obviously uh public
opinion turned on her pretty quickly uh
you know everyone calling her baby
killer and wanting to string her up and
all this other kind of stuff
so since she had confessed uh when she
went to trial uh you know they were
pretty sure that
um you know she was going to obviously
be charged with murder and she was going
to be found guilty of murder because she
had confessed to it so basically they
were trying to all it was coming down to
was whether she was going to get life in
prison or whether she was going to get
the death penalty because they did try
to get the death penalty
um the jury however
uh they did find her guilty like pretty
quickly but they did not think that the
death penalty was warranted because they
actually were swayed a little bit
um by all of the [__] that had happened
to her like in her life and stuff like
that so they're like you know that's
obviously it's [__] up what she did
but we don't think that she deserves the
death penalty so they
um did not give her that interestingly
normally
um in a in a town as small as this
because like I said it's Union South
Carolina so it's a very small town and
normally you would think that the
defense attorney would try to get a
change of venue because you know they
they would think that you know the
defendant wouldn't be able to get um a
fair trial because everybody knew her I
mean this is a kind of town where
everybody knew everybody you know what I
mean so it's like how's she going to get
a fair trial but it actually ended up
working in her favor because they said
if we went to like a larger town
uh you know like Columbia or something
like that
where nobody really knew much about her
except what they saw in the media then
it would be a lot easier uh to paint her
as a monster uh whereas the defensive
was trying to drum up a Little Bit of
Sympathy for her just so she didn't get
the death penalty they knew that she was
gonna be guilty of murder and she was
so yeah so she was guilty got life in
prison although she is eligible for
parole
next year I don't know if she's gonna
get it or not because she's been in
there she's been in there for 30 years
so she served like 30 years then I could
let her out so I I doubt they'll let her
out I mean if they do
I don't know but so she's um at a
correctional center in Greenwood South
Carolina and
um she's been kind of like I said a
troublemaker in there uh she's gotten a
lot of she's had drugs smuggled in uh
marijuana and [__] like that she has
also had sex with at least two
correctional officers working at the
prison both of whom were suspended
for for that suspended or fired uh yeah
fire I think one of them was suspended
and one of them was fired yeah okay but
for having a relationship a relationship
with her uh so there was that and uh
yeah so she's always kind of getting
into trouble
now she basically says
um
she denies that she killed her children
to be with a man and she's very very sad
that everybody thinks that about her
um you know but I mean her she maintains
that you know I wasn't in my right state
of mind I was really upset I was
suicidal and it's just I was gonna go
with them and then at the last minute I
didn't and she feels really bad about it
and yada yada but
I don't know I don't know if I buy it
and she's been uh corresponding with she
was corresponding with one dude who was
her boyfriend boyfriend even though I
don't think they ever met in real life
they were doing that you know prison
letter exchange thing
and they were gonna get married and all
this other kind of stuff but I think uh
eventually like they didn't correspond
anymore so she's still looking for
love
still looking for male companionship
she's [__] the guards at the prison
for Christ's sake yeah what she looks
like now you know what I saw a picture
of her the most recent one that I've
seen of her was from a couple years ago
and she actually looks much better than
she looked back in the 80s well because
in the 80s she had those big giant
glasses and that terrible like big permy
hair yeah now she actually looks you
know I hate to say but she actually
looks good okay I mean she's she's quite
an attractive woman so it's it doesn't
surprise me that some of the guards were
like oh right you know what I mean like
she doesn't look all skanky or like
nothing like that because you know I
mean she's been in prison a long time
yeah I mean she works in prison she's
kind of like I think she's female prison
though yeah yeah
but yeah it's not it's not a not the
same kind of violent atmosphere
yeah it's really not I mean [__] does
happen in there but it's technically
it's really not the same as the male
person it's not because you know you get
a bunch of dudes together like a bunch
of dude criminals
yeah that's the women not so much yeah
from what I've heard based on little
programs and [__] that I've seen over
the years is that most of those female
prisons
they end up going to these uh small kind
of like little satellite camps that are
they don't have real high populations
that they're if they're good they'll go
to these little satellite camps where
they'll have little jobs that they do
some of them they actually kind of
bust them down to uh
like uh County offices and they'll clean
offices in there after hours like
janitors and uh so I guess you could say
they're kind of like not really work
release just very minimum security
because women tend not to be flight
risks and they're not violent a lot most
of the time anyway
uh but my understanding is that the
atmosphere is basically
um
girls in relationship women and girls in
relationship with each other and there's
like little family units form where
there's the husband and the wife and the
adopted children and it's it's a bunch
of relationships
that they're long-term prisoners that
that's yeah
so it's not dudes fight kill each other
in prison yeah
well dudes fight and kill each other on
yeah
they got [__] high testosterone
levels they're packed in there and
they're [__] aggressive and they're
in a bad mood and they're constantly
trying to assert dominance and [__]
scare off [__] attackers and [__]
scare off enemies so it
projecting [__] violence's strength
and and error I guess you say an image
of violence and strength as a way of
keeping yourself safe in a Men's prison
well yeah isn't that one of the things
they always tell like new prisoners
should go in there it's like you got to
go [__] go in there and fight and
fight the biggest yeah the biggest
meanest looking dude get your ass kicked
and fight literally let everybody know
that you're good that you will fight
right so no one will fight yeah right
like I said the the female prisons are a
generally different Dynamic and I'm not
saying they don't have fights and [__]
in there because they do they're
fighting over girls though but yeah it's
it's not yeah you bet you anything like
the same yeah
chicks are not the same although I mean
we've talked about some crazy [__] on
this show yeah that were just as crazy
as dudes it just doesn't happen as often
you know what I mean not like in in a my
understanding women
um in a prison situation feel isolated
and under threat and they don't like to
women do not like to be alone when
they're threatened so they start
grouping up in little groups which makes
sense sure right guys no when they're
threatened to uh they become Islands
basically
because they think everybody's have to
get it yeah paranoia and [__] yeah
all right so
um if you want
to run some once you run some
commercials throw some more ice in there
and a little bit more drink too and then
yeah I'll run a couple commercials and
then
when we get back we're gonna talk about
Andrea Yates which is a lot more
complicated case uh just because like I
said there's a lot of severe mental
illness involved and
not gonna lie I don't really feel bad
for Susan Smith I kind of feel bad for
Andrew Yates I mean she's
she's really got problems so yeah so um
we will be back in just a couple of
minutes
[Music]
again
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I don't know
all right we're back again got drinks
filled up
we're heading back into another case
Jeff yard said given that there are
women prisoners that have and love their
kids I'm curious on how they would feel
about someone like Susan Smith being in
their midst I am also curious she didn't
seem to have complained about
um you know any kind of treatment or any
kind of way from being in prison which
I'm sure she would have complained about
now they probably felt sorry for her
maybe they did yeah I don't know
oh yeah those guys are bad yeah Karen
Lee said wow 30 years does not seem that
long yeah and I mean like I said I don't
know if they're gonna let her out that's
I mean she's just eligible for parole
next year because she served 30 years
but I don't know if they're gonna let
her out chances them letting her out on
her first parole here no
especially it comes up every year I mean
especially as notorious
54.
yeah 53 probably yeah
no we're not gonna let her out maybe
yeah she's she's exactly a year older
than I am when she's 60 they might yeah
because they're like well you probably
could use like a little old lady and you
probably won't do any harm
yeah I'm just gonna sap all the life out
of her
yeah I mean you know I can't be too mad
about it gonna say I don't honestly I
agree with the jury I don't think they
should have given her the death penalty
but
um
I I really don't think they should let
her out at least until she's like very
old
because I don't know to me she doesn't
seem like at least from what I've heard
from other people that know her that
visit her in prison like other people
that serve time with her and stuff it
doesn't really seem like she's matured
to any great degree
so I don't know if I'd really trust her
to be able to get a chance that's what
I'm saying it's not a dynamic I mean she
was only 23 when she went in there she's
Frozen at 23. right and even when she
was 23 she seemed very yeah teenagery
yeah and she still seems kind of
teenagery to me yeah that's like that
she's at you right it doesn't develop in
much in prison right it doesn't really
seem like she's right she doesn't really
seem and she doesn't really seem to
I mean at least from what I've heard of
her like saying like recently she
doesn't really seem to grasp like the
gravity of what she did she doesn't seem
all that sorry about it
um you know what I mean and it's I uh
David her husband her ex-husband
um he had wanted her to get the death
penalty because yeah you know he he just
he couldn't [__] and he was
especially infuriated that she had lied
about it like she knew that those kids
were dead the whole time and like tried
to blame it on somebody else all that
time yeah
here's the thing
if they were to release her she's not a
threat she doesn't have the physical
power or the motivation to do it her
kids are dead she can't have any more
kids
so you could let her out I don't think
she'd do any damage
but you know
I don't know
you could let her out it wouldn't make
much difference it probably wouldn't no
um but
[__] I don't know would I let her out
I'd have to meet her yeah it's hard for
me to say like unless I'm just going by
interviews I've read with her like from
Recently like from a year or two ago
like she just seems still
keeping her in there doesn't burn the
kids back yeah I mean she just still
seems very narcissistic she seems like
she's not
all that sorry about it like she kind of
makes noises like she's sorry and she
feels bad about it but I don't know
anything that's there no I I don't she
doesn't really seem to feel that much
remorse about it I don't think you knew
that's there she's very self-absorbed
she seems really self-absorbed yeah she
turned inward on herself yeah that she
just protected herself and I think she
was like that before yeah I mean
everything was like me me me like what
she wanted
so that's what I mean about her being
very immature she really didn't she just
worried about what she just look at it
like uh
keeping her in there doesn't bring the
kids back
letting her out probably wouldn't make
any difference I don't think yeah it
seems to like not make a difference one
way or the other to be honest it would
just be a toss of the coin or whether or
not I don't think they'll let her out
they probably I don't think so like I
said someone as notorious as that right
I don't know they might let her out
later but her first Pearl hearing I
don't know they might let her wait
another but we'll see we'll have to see
what happens next year but
Victor said wow I didn't realize how
young she was when this happened yeah
she married when she was 19.
but she was already pregnant then so
she'd had two kids by the time she was
23. some people might have
pity on her thinking well she's uh
backwards and immature because she was a
kid when she did this and then she's
been in prison all this time so she
hasn't changed let her out here they
might say that
I don't know yeah I don't know that's
what I mean I just I don't know how I
feel about it I don't feel bad for her I
don't but like you said it seems like it
won't make a difference I'd have to meet
her yeah
okay all right so let's talk about
Andrea Yates and like I said this is a
lot more complex case I guess just in
the sense of like all this [__] crazy
[__] going on
so Andrea Yates in case you didn't know
we'll just kind of give you a little
summary of what happened before we get
like in all the details and stuff
back in 2001 uh this happened in Texas
by the way Victor's in in the uh hey
Victor what's up it was these women that
made Victor gay
yeah it's whatever the whatever the show
topic is that's what made victories
I'm sorry I'm sorry what happened to you
Victor
but yeah yeah
uh yeah
these bad women
um I forgot what I was saying I don't
know you where did you interrupted me
yeah and now I totally lost it was good
you were talking about the new case I
know but I I was going somewhere and now
I can't remember but um but yeah oh okay
so uh Governor so 2001 she's from Texas
yeah and she um drowned all five of her
children in the bathtub one by one uh
they arranged in age the oldest was
seven years old the youngest was six
months old it was four boys and one
little girl the baby was a little girl
so yeah seven man this is also that's
old enough to know what the hell is
going on uh well yeah yeah we'll get
into that this is like also pretty yeah
this is the one that [__] but like I
said this whole situation is horrific
just everything smashed this woman when
I heard about it everything about this I
was messed up she crazy
so now think about it like I said it's
spoiler alert uh she actually did get in
2001 um she was she didn't get the death
penalty they did seek the death penalty
but she didn't get it uh because jury
thought it wasn't warranted
um she did get life in prison
but then uh five years later the
conviction was overturned and she was
actually given
um uh Not Guilty by reason of insanity
and was sent to a mental hospital where
she still is to this day and like I said
she does not really seem to want to be
let out because they have told her that
she is she can petition you know to be
let out that doesn't mean they're going
to let her out but she can petition to
be let out and she always waves her
right to do that she really does not
seem uh to want to be let out she seems
content where she is uh like I said this
woman I'm not excusing it but this woman
is severely severely mentally ill one
psychiatrist that treated her said that
this was the sickest patient that they
had ever
encountered
um and we'll get into like yeah this
this [__] woman this this is crazy
so and I will note that getting an
insanity defense like a successful
Insanity defense in Texas is very very
difficult because the um the criteria is
very very stringent
um but they actually did think it was
warranted in her case yeah you have to
not know it was wrong
pretty much yeah she seemed the weird
thing about she seemed to know it was
wrong but
like I said she seemed to have which
we'll get into she seemed to have like
some really bizarre delusions about why
she was doing it yeah you know what I
mean yeah like she thought she I don't
know if she thought she was doing
something good but kind of yeah I mean
she had some real
problems
so yeah so she's still in a mental
facility too this day and like I said
does not seem to want to be let out she
was actually transferred to a lower
security one but she's still there
so she was born in Houston Texas
and had four older siblings
now she was raised Catholic but not
super super religious as far as I could
uh find
now kind of like Susan Smith although to
to an even more like a greater degree
Andrea Yates was a very very high
achiever uh they said she was very very
intelligent she was actually uh she
graduated in 1982 and she was actually
class valedictorian uh she was capped In
The Swim Team she was officer in the
Honor Society and everybody said she was
just like a go-getter she was just like
very very intelligent
um very high achieving one of those
however something that goes along with
this personality type sometimes
is depression and eating disorders uh
she had bulimia
uh a lot uh you know growing up through
High School something about this chick
always reminded me of Shelley Duval yeah
she does kind of look a little bit like
that
um so yeah so she was obviously like you
know doing all this [__] on um on the
outside like I said very very high
achieving very top of her class and all
that other kind of stuff and then behind
the scenes you know bulimia other
depression uh you know suicide ideation
things of that nature so that was gone
kind of going on when she was a teenager
now she um went to nursing school and
she actually graduated and worked as a
nurse for several years I believe she
worked for as a nurse for eight years uh
from 1986 until 1994.
um so yeah so and everybody that member
said she was
um very compassionate she was a people
pleaser which again I think that kind of
factored into some [__] later on
um and again very high achieving very
intelligent
now in the summer of 1989.
she meets the guy that would become her
husband whose name is Rusty Yates
now she met him he also lived in the
same apartment complex that she lived in
and they met and uh got married
now they got married few years later I
think it was 1993.
and David or that was sorry that was
Susan's husband Rusty we're talking
about Rusty now
Rusty was very very religious in kind of
a weird and not like in a Mainline kind
of way he was
um he was kind of an acolyte of this
weird what's the dude's name Michael
hornecki or something like that who was
this weird Street Preacher essentially
never heard him he was very very
fundamentalist very much
um you know women or the devil and you
have to they have to be your servants or
they're all into witchcraft that kind of
[__] also they had um okay come up with
this [__] the Bible they say that's not
anything but that well I know but I mean
just they're just saying you know that's
women should be subservient if you if
you don't make them be subservient then
they're just they just become witches
that kind of [__]
um also they had kind of like a
quiverful thing going on where it's like
it was your duty to have as many
children as possible which uh is one of
the things that caused a lot of the
problems
so Rusty he marries Andrea and basically
he's like we're gonna have as many
children as nature as God will allow
so basically he just wants to knock her
up right away and she's just gonna keep
having babies like forever now
apparently she kind of got into the [__]
too I don't know if she was into it like
because she was really into it or she
was just into it because she wanted to
make him happy I'm not really entirely
sure even before they were married like
I said all through her teenage years
um she had uh you know severe pretty
severe mental problem she had a lot of
Eating Disorders uh depression
um she had had some suicide attempts she
had actually I Believe been um in a
psychiatric hospital for a short time
when she was a teenager as well so she
had some um some problems prior to this
so yeah so he wants to have as many
babies as possible so you know easy for
him he doesn't have to like carry them
in his [__] body but you know what I
mean so uh he was actually an engineer
at Nasa so he made like some decent
money
but he was still like a religious weirdo
though
so they buy this house in Friendswood
Texas
now they have their first kid uh whose
name is Noah in 1994.
now not too long after Noah was born
Rusty got another job uh and this was in
Florida it was actually in a Seminole
which I think is over on the west coast
like over near St Petersburg I think
it's kind of over in that area
so they go over there
another thing that Rusty and his weird
religious beliefs were into
was that they were very into
um this whole thing like where the world
and materialism and stuff like that was
evil so it's like you shouldn't have too
much stuff or like too many modern
conveniences or things like that so he
was always kind of seeking to downsize
um but the thing about it is that he
would always downsize her stuff but not
his stuff which I was like well that
yeah yeah that's typical isn't it like
he's like hey let's have a let's have a
garage sale and we'll sell all your [__]
we'll keep my [__] I need this [__]
though yeah but all your stuff can go
because that's just crap yeah but yeah
so it was it was that kind of situation
so they had lived in like a decent house
because like I said he was an engineer
like he had like a good job and he like
got paid quite a bit so they lived in a
nice house in Texas but then when they
moved to Florida they moved to like this
kind of
um trailer
you know yeah they lived in a trailer
for a little while it was temporary
um
well yeah we'll get into it okay
now so Andrea has a couple more kids
um a couple more boys
and another thing too is that
um one of the things that he wouldn't
let her have because of course she I
mean she had a job and an apartment and
everything like that prior to this she
was a nurse she'd been a nurse for like
eight years she had her own place all
this other kind of stuff but when she
married this douche
uh he's like not only do you have to
start pumping out babies but you have to
live in this small trailer well and now
she's got three kids all of whom are
little in this little bitty trailer
um and you're not allowed to have
disposable diapers you're not allowed
you have to have cloth diapers with
usable stuff trying to save money [__]
that Jesus Christ gotta wash them all by
hand and then yeah oh that's so gross
yeah it's okay she had to do it that's
what I mean they're gonna say well they
did that back in the Bible
that's what I mean and like I said it's
very easy for the dude in this situation
because he doesn't have to do any of
this crap and I'm just any pension and
I'm gonna say just right here I'm not
saying that Rusty was necessarily
responsible for everything that happened
but he for sure contributed because all
that pressure on her he was yeah I mean
basically it was his idea like you need
to have as many babies as possible you
need to live in this tiny little trailer
you need to like not work not have a
social structure he did kind of isolate
her it's very he's very very controlling
and it didn't have to be this way no of
course not two houses up or three houses
up on this road here there's a nice big
house there
and uh it's a blonde man and a woman I
saw the woman she was at the uh at the
store what do you call it uh Dollar
General at the Dollar General store with
her kids the Dollar General she's got
nine kids and more coming
and she's good looking blonde
probably in her she's in her 30s
and she's in there with the kids
and it's like a little army of trained
soldiers
some of them were in the
cart that she's pushing and the rest of
them were all kind of like marching
behind and doing around and they were
very well ordered
and a little boy saw me and he goes
strong man
yeah like that they all started laughing
you live up the street yeah yeah and he
says yeah you're famous because your
kids run out and [__] uh get candy
from the garbage truck because yeah
every time the garbage truck comes they
got candy for them they bring them on
and they run down there and they do
wonders the garbage men are giving them
candy one at the time they and they uh
they all come out like all organized
they're all organized and like get a
piece of candy yeah I don't think
they're religious he's just they're just
having a lot of kids they just really
like kids yeah
every one of them little blondes yeah
yeah it's like the mission you know it
doesn't have to be a [__] and my mom
you know she came from a family of nine
uh yeah my mom was uh they had eight
yeah my mama came from a family of nine
and uh which I can't imagine yeah her
they were religious though and [__]
it was like a Maximum Security Prison in
a certain way everybody was dying to get
the [__] out of there at 16 you know 17.
because he just you had to share
everything and [__] everything was
communal living you got real sick of
that a lot of times and not in all
situations because I know some people
just really do like children and they
want to have a lot of them but it does
seem like in the majority of these cases
it's usually like some kind of weird
religious thing
look at the [__] Duggars for Christ's
sake
let's not we should do a show about them
I get demonetized well it's a weird
thing you can't have all those kids if
you can't afford them
you know what I mean but this this
family of the street could afford them
yeah evidently yeah like I said maybe
it's like they're having fun they just
seem to really like it and you look at
her man you wouldn't think that she had
that many kids her her build is just
like normal she's not she's you know
slender
some people some yeah some [__] are
lucky like that just snatch you like a
clown car people just jumping out
they're running away those kids all look
to be the same age almost dude I mean
like the difference between them and she
must be constantly pregnant
that's what I'm saying yeah I don't know
yeah like James says I got seven
siblings that's crazy yeah my mom does
too I actually I have three my parents
have uh because I have two brothers and
one sister
so my parents had four and even that I
can't imagine yeah I mean we're spaced
out we weren't all little at the same
time like I was born in 72 like my
brother wasn't born until four like I
was four like when he was born and then
and then my sister wasn't born until 79
and then my other brother wasn't born
until 1986. so there's kind of like a a
big gap so it's not like we were just
like a bunch of kids running around in
Diapers at the same time which that
sounds like a nightmare but my I mean my
mom loves kids yeah
so she she not only had four but she
also ran a daycare for a long time like
in the house and also like ran a daycare
because she just loves children I was
like I didn't get that Gene I was the
only child my parents weren't together
long enough to have any more in me
I know I always thought that was weird
because I have never experienced I mean
other than the first four years of my
life when I was an only child but I
don't really remember that I have never
experienced life without siblings yeah
so it must be I've known a lot of people
that were only children and I was like
wow that must be weird
I don't know any different I mean but
yeah they you wouldn't know any
different would you but no I was just in
a constant battle against stepdads yeah
I wouldn't trade it though because my
siblings are awesome yeah they're all
just basically we're all very much alike
which is weird because I've heard from
other people I know that have siblings
they're always like oh my God we're so
different it's like me and my siblings
are not even though like we're all super
super similar even though we're like
pretty far apart in age
so yeah so they keep having all these
babies they're living in this little
bitty trailer
now by the time they finally moved back
to Texas they moved to Houston
and now they're downsizing even more and
move into like a [__] motorhome right
so now they live in a [__] motorhome
like in a mobile home park thing and
this poor woman you know her husband
goes off you know toddles off to work
every day and she's stuck here with
these little tiny babies in this little
tiny I think they said that it was like
350 square feet or something like that
with no no disposable diapers none of
that kind of stuff so you know great
now as I mentioned Andrea Yates had had
struggles with mental health pretty much
her entire life it also ran in her
family which um I believe her
who was one of her parents and some of
her siblings and maybe like some other
people in the family too had committed
suicide or attempted it because
depression things like that do tend to
run in families uh and her family did
seem to have a very very high instance
of it
uh so she had had that PRI but the thing
about it was that it seemed like each
time she had a kid
um that she would get you know you get
postpartum depression a lot of women
have that
um it's probably like I think it's one
in ten I think is the the thing that I
heard postpartum depression uh but then
there's a an even more extreme version
of that one in a thousand women get
which is postpartum psychosis
um which is where basically you get
delusional
um and a very common delusion that women
that that have this get is that they
feel that they're going to do harm to
their children or they're going to kill
their children
um and it's fairly common
um but that does seem to be what she had
like I said she'd been in and out with
psychiatrists so she knew that she had
issues but it seemed like every time she
had another kid like it would just
exacerbate it further you know my mom
was in the state department one of the
women that worked at the consulate with
her in Brazil
had a kid and went through the
postpartum depression thing that they
were talking about they were treating
her
and uh husband turned his back on her
and she grabbed the baby and jumped out
the window 23rd floor
yeah that's [__] sad it's not that
uncommon yeah and then they evacuated
the dude you know and they replaced oh
that's horrible yeah well that's the
thing that we've talked about that
before because pregnancy
and you you know you have some
experiences too because like you know
how much hormones and like [__] like
that can like [__] you up hell yeah
pregnancy is very extreme it's a very
extreme uh you know cocktail of [__]
going on in your body it's you know
um and it actually surprises me that it
doesn't happen more often yeah for
people new to the show I'm very open
about the [__] that I do I do hormone
therapy and I [__] around with all kinds
of
anabolic steroids and stuff just for
anti-aging and Therapeutics and working
out and I've had some hormonal profiles
sometimes temporarily that are just
[__] up really heavy in progesterone
real low in estrogen and high and
testosterone or the other way around
where you've got a lot of estrogen in
you and a lot of progesterone and uh
some of that [__] Trent like trend
you've you're a werewolf on on one end
of the spectrum at the same time you're
also like a pregnant woman man you're
[__] weird as [__]
um and you kind of
gives you a taste of
what women are like what what their
Eternal world is like a lot of fear and
anxiety worry wart stuff yeah
um feelings the insecurity yep you know
and well so I understand it you know
that's what made me laugh is that yeah
so when he told me finally like what
trend was making him feel like yeah like
after he kind of like got over it a
little bit and he was telling me about
like this that and the other thing and I
said to him I was like oh so like women
feel all the time yeah and the funny
thing about it is like I told another
one of our female friends about it and
she said the exact same thing oh like we
feel all the time I was like yeah that's
what I said yeah I was like now you know
there's always a lot of stuff on the
internet you know they have female
psychologists and [__] and scientists
and they're [__] one of them you can
you can [__] search on there this
British guy does an interview with this
um psychologist and she's female and she
just talks about the what testosterone
actually does and the name of the video
is called testosterone is a hell of a
drug it's a [__] great absolutely
true it changes you I think for the
better
um but if you start going into [__]
super physiological [__] doses of
tests and then certain
like 19 North testosterone certain
certain Esters like Trend alone man
Tran is [__] notoriously mind-bending
that's the Mount Everest of them it's
like the LSD of steroids yeah you were
like a crazy person oh yeah you're okay
for about
two and a half months three months
month four and five I was on it for five
months
because I thought I could do it you know
because you're you're kind of out of
your mind
but you don't realize you don't realize
your mind you think everything's normal
but everybody else is like they're just
making this up they're making it became
what the [__] is wrong with you yeah
became basically like the goblin [__]
from [__] Spider-Man
pretty [__] evil kind of like a
descent into evil weird
although your simpy is [__] too it's
it's weird
yeah erratic Behavior but I'm just
saying that so you have some experience
with yeah well like a hormonal imbalance
like that that can absolutely yeah make
you [__] yeah because the hormones
are about feelings
so this bitch's feelings are running out
of [__] you know uh running out of
control and then she's having this weird
ideation and stuff on top of that you
know weird fantasies and paranoias and
mental Illusions I was having Illusions
too you know or how do you call it
delusions yeah you know they weren't
that bad but
because I knew they were I kind of knew
they were delusions I'd have to come to
Jenny with I had delusions that she was
cheating on me but I'd already been
warned that tread does that that'll yeah
yeah because that's a very common I just
had to come and check that meant on real
common for guys and I just had to check
like they always think their wives or
girlfriends yeah it makes you think that
you're cheating on and so you're not
cheating on me are you he goes no I said
I thought also that's like when the [__]
would I have time to do that yeah
together all the time
it's just feelings weird feelings
yeah yeah but like I said so you can see
how yeah Tammy said there's a channel
called Fundy Fridays yeah I love Fundy
Fridays actually uh does a lot on the
Duggars yeah I haven't watched any of
her stuff on the Duggars but yeah I've
watched some of her other stuff she's
great uh she was kissed by fire says
I've got two what kids had them four
years apart so I wouldn't have to deal
with two tiny babies now I'm raising a
puppy and it's like having a baby all
over again yeah I mean they grow up
faster though well that's true yeah the
fur the fur babies are because we have
we have kitties yeah and our kitty
Pookie is just like she's pretty much
just she thinks she's a child she thinks
she's a human child yeah she doesn't
understand it
and raised her she's
dead she was abandoned by her mom or her
mom got killed or something somebody
just found her that was just a story
that came she just came out of a litter
and she was selling the litter right but
we got her when she was really little
like her eyes were still blue yeah
so that's really she may have been
weaned a little too young I think maybe
it's hard to say but she's yeah she's
like our kid she follows us around
everywhere and some most of the time the
show you can see her walking around
waiting for us to come home she'll be
waiting by the door that's why if you
see Spock like moving around back there
it's not ghosts she's back there like
pushing on because she's like you guys
are not paying attention to me come on
so yeah
so they're in this [__] motorhome
right back in Texas
and they have a fourth kid Luke
and after this Andrea really really
seemed to spiral downwards
um this is bad enough that she has all
of these had all of these mental issues
before which are exacerbated by these
pregnancies and this postpartum
depression also this whole
Fundamentalist
kind of Dogma that they're getting into
she is also and this I think is relevant
too and you see this a lot in these
types of girls that grew up like in high
school and they're super high Achievers
you know they're usually top of their
class and stuff but then like they have
eating disorders and things those types
of girls are usually
people Pleasers and they're usually
super super critical of themselves
they're perfectionists and they feel as
though nothing they do will ever ever be
good enough so they're always like
striving and striving and striving to be
better but they always feel like they're
failing you know what I mean and I
really feel like Andrea had that going
on too she was trying to
have all these babies because that's
what Rusty wanted she was having she was
trying to be the perfect mother because
that's what her the religion was telling
her that that was her job was now
um and she just felt like she was
failing that she was [__] it up and
so she was just wallowing in
self-loathing I guess
so
um so around this time not too long
after she had her fourth baby
she essentially had a nervous breakdown
um in 1999 uh June of 1999 Rusty comes
home and finds her just completely he's
like she was just sitting there
trembling and basically chewing on her
fingers like not her fingernails chewing
on her fingers like self-harming is what
she was doing
um the following day she uh a suicide
attempt she took a huge overdose of
pills
so they took her to the hospital and
they put her on a antidepressants
for a little while
um but she did another suicide attempt
actually she was going to uh cut her own
throat and she begged her husband to
please just let her kill herself
um you know because she just couldn't
take it anymore so they put her in the
hospital again and at this point
um they seemed to find a combination of
medications that worked for her uh prior
to this I believe they had only given
her antidepressants however when they
gave her antidepressants and an
anti-psychotic Haldol
um that actually seemed to improve her
condition pretty much immediately like
she almost went back to normal like the
way that she was prior to having all of
these kids
now one thing that they suggested that
Rusty do
was that look your poor wife is with
these [__] four babies in this 350
square foot [__] bus essentially it
was like a converted bus they were
living in yeah it's like please get her
a real [__] house you know what I
mean they told her they told him it's
like this you know she shouldn't have to
live like that it's it's not helping her
situation who told him that uh the
doctors basically were like it's just
not a good environment for her to be in
it's like she's very isolated she
doesn't have any friends yeah um you
know what I mean she doesn't have a job
she doesn't have anything out of the
home anymore she's a dude's got money
she's lost her identity essentially this
dude
well he just seemed
just seem trolling [__] to me is what
he seems like he just wanted to keep her
under his thumb his religion said that
women should be subservient and they
should just have babies and that's their
job to just take care of kids and suffer
apparently nothing wrong with a woman
just being a housewife it's just that
you [__] don't [__] make it a prison
we're playing out in the backyard and I
am not and I absolutely do not like like
I said I'm not real into kids I never
had any kids anything like that it's
just not for me
um but I do absolutely do not judge
women that want to be stay-at-home moms
and like just they want to be a mom and
that's the role that's cool like if they
chose that people got to come from
somewhere and that's what they want to
do then cool but then also cool like if
you want to have a kid and it's like
well I'm going to take the kid to
daycare I'm gonna have my own life I'm
gonna have a job and that's awesome too
like it's but it just should be up to
you like what's your choices I was just
watching this uh talk by a woman who was
talking about feminism and stuff and
where it came from and how old it is and
what kind of woman was actually involved
in starting it and everything and she
goes on you guys look gotta look at the
statistics not all women are the same
all right well obviously some women and
it's and the majority of them are very
happy as like moms and Housewives and
they keep the population going there are
other portions of them that have don't
want anything to do with kids that's
just it's just not in them and they're
not lesbian they're straight or you know
mostly straight or something I don't
think it has anything to do with she
went on and said then there's some women
that are lesbian and they're kind of
like feminist and they're actually kind
of competing with the men trying to get
Prestige positions and stuff and that
they're in this movement and because
they're kind of running that movement or
they're very high incident she can just
explain it better than than I can
they really don't have the right to talk
for the average woman because the
average woman is not motivated for that
she doesn't want to work a corporate job
really uh she'd be happy just stayed at
home raising kids and having fun and
taking care of the house and that's a
very important role in all societies
you've got to have a breeding population
if not then you'll run out of people
quickly well the thing about it is that
I'm a big advocate of just you know do
that if you want to right but if you
don't want to do that you don't have to
do it yeah yeah like somebody got to
clean the [__] house but it don't got
to be me you know what I mean somebody
got to do it I don't care if it's a man
you don't do it because you work outside
that's what I'm saying right
I'll [__] cook yeah she comes home
from work I got food ready for it yeah I
am a cook right all right and that's the
way I mean that's the way it should be
that's just a division of labor yeah you
know what I mean I don't see labor as
gendered and I think that's like a lot
of people think that it's like oh
cleaning the house or taking care of
kids that's something women should be
doing not necessarily like a dude can do
it too dudes are [__] they're they
can also do it yeah so it's like you
know if back before this war started
they had some Russian guys students uh
Vladimir Putin was [__] visiting them
and one of the guys raised his hands he
says because you know Vladimir had this
damn image of being Macho the kid asked
him he said you said Mr President what
should we do as boys to become more like
men and he goes learn how to cook and
they laughed he goes what are you
laughing for well you think the Mongols
[__] had their moms with them when
they were you know out in the field
fighting these wars no they knew how to
cook since real men know how to cook
well see if that's what I'm saying I
think that everybody should be able to
do just regular life maintenance [__]
yeah everybody should be able to kind of
like cook some basic [__] everybody
should know how to clean stuff everybody
should know how to do like basic Karma
maintain in your own area of that kind
of [__] like Jen keeps it pretty clean
in here because she's in here all the
time
yeah you know what I mean I just come in
a vacuum yeah that's pretty yeah that's
pretty much all this yeah like I keep
[__] wiped down and stuff it's a little
bit dusty but that's all right it
doesn't bother I mean the rest of the
house I'll vacuum but she's she's at
work yeah I'm not home but I don't have
to leave the house and make money I got
my VA money right you know and like I
said she got a lot of work right and
that's just the way and like I said it's
that's why I think the problem is when
labor like that is gendered and
absolutely shouldn't be like I said
everybody should clean up their own
space everybody should be able to cook
their meals if they need to Sharp knives
fire and meat man men should know all
about that
I know and it's like it's so funny
because I just feel like for a long time
it's like oh cooking like in the kitchen
that was like seen as a womany thing but
it's like oh barbecuing now that's a
nice man's thing yeah which is dumb it's
just like it's all the same thing it's
all cooking it's all cooking everybody
should be able to like just cook if you
don't have to be like in pastries man
yeah you don't have to be like a chef or
nothing like Thomas yeah but it's like
you know well you know what I mean but
you're really but you're a really good
coach I was trained so I'm just saying
but everybody should know how to make a
few basic things making bread making I'm
making yogurt now yeah my yogurt's
[__] good it was good like we had
some of it yesterday yeah make it in the
instant pot making yogurt in the instant
pot yeah and also it takes a long time
then you gotta sift it yeah yeah I mean
it's a pain in the ass but it's good
it's [__] real good you can just keep
working on it working out until it
becomes cream cheese yeah
make some cream cheese we'll get some
Bangles yeah
but yeah so so I'm just saying but the
fact that Rusty had these really
antiquated
ideas of what she should be doing when
and I kind of feel like maybe she
believed in it too but I feel like more
that she went along with it because she
loved him and she was a people pleaser
and she wanted to make him happy and
like I said like a lot of women that are
these kind of like high achieving that
were these high achieving girls with
these eating disorders and stuff they
usually are just like constantly strive
they have to be perfect everything they
do it has to be perfect and if it's not
perfect then they just completely like
shut down because they failed and so
then the self-loathing starts you know
what I mean and I think that that she uh
had that as well so yeah so she has this
they put her on
um some antidepressants and they put her
on an antipsychotic Haldol and she
actually really did seem to improve
greatly um you know they said she went
almost back to the way she was prior to
having children uh so they actually
moved to a real house for Christ's sake
because Rusty didn't have the money
um so he actually did he did that at
least like he did buy a house when they
told him it's like for Christ's sake
your wife's living in a [__] bus so
you know what I mean with no diapers or
anything so he actually buys her a real
house and for a while
everything seemed okay like she seemed
almost back to normal there was some
video of her like having a little
birthday party for one of the kids and
she seemed fine
however as time went on uh it really did
seem that she deteriorated again uh had
another nervous breakdown another couple
of suicide attempts and uh was sent to a
psychiatric hospital uh again and at
this point she was diagnosed with
postpartum psychosis
now the psychiatrist who talked to her
at this time period whose name was Dr
Eileen starbranch
she strongly recommended that the couple
have no more children because she's like
every time you have it because they had
four at this point they're like every
time she has another child her mental
state deteriorates and it's and it's
getting worse like each time so it's
like please please do not have any more
children
um you know because it will just [__]
her up more it's just like you know all
of the progress that we made on her just
will will disappear
so
then Rusty
whose whole idea is like we need to have
as many kids as possible
seven weeks after Andrea was discharged
from the hospital
she was
pregnant again
they actually went to the psychiatrist
and said she's going off her
antipsychotic medication so she can get
pregnant again
and the psychiatrists are like please do
not take her off her medication
because that was helping her and you
can't just stop taking that medication
you have to like slowly you know what I
mean you have to like be monitored
through all of that stuff because she
was on like a big cocktail of them but
they were helping her
but they were she was going to go off
from cold turkey because Rusty's like no
we want to have another baby oh really
yeah we as in she was in there on this
too he wants to have another yeah I kind
of feel like it's probably what the
situation was oh and she's like oh yeah
totally I totally yeah
if he jams so many into her
so quick that's what I mean
this motherfucker's not well grounded in
reality and no he's absolutely not no
he's he's often uh religious land he
read it in the Bible so it's true
or somebody told him it was in the Bible
so it's true that's another thing yeah
you can go into that Pauline material
and pull anything out of Paul
and make anything out of it like Legos
and it has it totally unrelated to
normal life
yeah it's just Street Preachers and [__]
yeah that was this whole [__]
situation yeah
but so and the thing about the saddest
thing about this is that Andrea
seemed aware
that having another baby
was gonna be a bad idea
of course she um
she seemed aware
that her mental illness was giving her
what they call homicidal ideation
she later confessed that she had been
thinking about killing her children for
two years before she actually did it and
she was terrified that she was actually
going to do it
it's and it seemed like she wasn't shy
about telling her husband about telling
psychiatrists about something like look
I'm having these horrible intrusive
thoughts about hurting my children and I
don't want to do that please help me
and it seemed like they tried to but it
wasn't I don't know it just wasn't
enough and it just felt like Rusty
one he was not super supportive like you
know he did do some things like to go
along with like what the psychiatrist
recommended but in the end he started
like blaming them and he's like blaming
the drugs she was on even though the
drugs were actually helping her
um and he was just he would say [__]
like oh people with depression they just
need a swift kick in the pants they'll
be fine and I'm just like really dude
like he just didn't really seem
I don't know he just really didn't seem
to take the severity of her illness he's
delusional all that seriously like I
think he thought that oh she's just
gonna snap out of it one day and we're
gonna have all these babies you know
what I mean
I think he thought like even after she
killed the kids
and you know and she got well I mean she
didn't get off because they sent her a
mental hospital but I think he was still
thinking to some extent he doesn't
anymore because I think he's remarried
now because this was a long time ago but
he seemed to think oh well when she gets
out of the mental hospital we'll get
back together and start having babies
again I'm like are you [__] high yeah
he's crazy
she's very severely ill this woman is
severely mentally ill and the idea and I
don't know if she's ever gonna be able
to get better well he's delusional just
to thinking that that they would let her
out yeah
I mean she is a very very sick person
and the saddest thing about this to me
is that she knew she knew how sick she
was and she was afraid that she was
going to do something she's like she
keeps having these thoughts she can't
you know and having these like actions
and she's like and she can't control it
and she was like terrified that she was
gonna do something and she kept trying
to get them to help her you know I mean
get them to stop her from doing it
um you know what I mean so that's what
kind of makes me sad about this whole
[__] thing is that there were so many
opportunities and yes like a lot of
psychiatrists did try to help her they
did put her on medication that did seem
to help but then like I said stupid
Rusty comes in is like oh we should have
another baby even though this
psychiatrist specifically said please
please please do not do that because
every time she has another baby like The
psychosis gets worse and worse like each
successive time and it's just gonna be a
bad idea but he wanted to do it anyway
so they did
so in March of 2000 uh she had a
daughter named Mary
and
everything seemed okay for a little
while
but then
um her dad died and she seemed to have a
really hard time like dealing with that
she didn't really have a lot of like um
family left she didn't have like a lot
of like wider support like I said she'd
kind of been isolated
she didn't have a job anymore she didn't
have like friends or a social network or
anything like that so I kind of feel
like the death of her dad was sort of
like a catalyst also
so after her dad died she seemed to
really go off the deep end
um she stopped taking her medication
which again you should never do that um
you know especially if you're not under
the supervision of your position
and she started uh self-harming
started getting real into the
fundamentalist stuff she started like
obsessively like reading the Bible [__]
like that
and then she
either she started like neglecting the
kids she stopped feeding the baby or
even that or she even like tried to give
the baby solid food and like almost
choked her things like that so she
really didn't know what the [__] was
going on anymore she like lost her
[__] marbles
so at this point
um she had to go back to the psychiatric
hospital so again she's been in and out
of psychiatric hospitals this whole time
like I said so she's clearly not well
now in April of 2001 uh she had this new
doctor his name was Dr uh Saeed now she
um was treated shortly she was uh there
I believe there was there was some kind
of thing where she was in a psychiatric
hospital but she was only there for a
week and then they made her leave
because
Rusty's insurance would only cover a
week of mental health stay so they were
like oh your insurance ran out bye so it
was like that kind of situation but I
don't know if that was this time or not
so she got treated with um Dr Saeed and
then she got released
but then
um about a month later she seemed to be
doing okay but then she went pretty much
like catatonic you know what I mean like
she just
went like that
and she
actually planned on this one particular
day in May of 2001 that this was the day
she was gonna drown her kids she filled
up the tub
and but then she for whatever reason
like decided she didn't do it
now the next day they sent her back to
the hospital
and the psychiatrist that talked to her
thought that probably she had filled the
tub up to drown herself because she was
clearly suicidal
stays under the care of Dr Syed until uh
the end of June of 2001.
now Rusty
uh left for work
and left Andrea alone with the children
something which Dr Saeed specifically
told him that he should not do he's like
she should be monitored all the time
because Andrea told him and told several
other psychiatrists that she was afraid
that she was going to harm her children
because she was having all these
intrusive ideations and she couldn't
stop them and so she was worried that
she was going to do it and so the
doctors were like please don't leave her
alone like have somebody watch her all
the time don't leave her alone with the
children because she's afraid she's
gonna harm them
however Rusty in His Infinite Wisdom
decided that oh well I can leave her
alone for an hour a day it'll be good
for her it'll be good for her
independence she'll be able to do all
even though every psychiatrist was like
please don't like please have somebody
monitor her at all times
um you know because obviously it's not
safe
but of course Rusty knows better
so he left her alone for an hour now
Andrea's mom was going to be coming over
like later like an hour after Rusty went
to work like to stay with her and to
like help her out with the kids and
stuff like that
but Rusty thought oh she'll be fine for
an hour alone with the kids
guess what
this was the hour when she
systematically drowned every one of her
five children in the bathtub one by one
man
started with the youngest one
drown him in the tub
took him into the bedroom put him in on
the bed put a blanket over him did it to
the next youngest one
and then did the kids know
probably the last ones did um well okay
what happened with like the first she
started with the young the youngest the
three younger the youngest boys
so she did the first one and then I
think she did the second one now I think
the third one
saw what she did the second one but
didn't really understand what was going
on you know what I mean yeah
um because he was just like well I don't
want to take a bath you know what I mean
it was just like that and then she just
picked him up and like put him in the
tub how old was how old was this kid
maybe these were
um like two three four or something like
that they were pretty little so right
the oldest woman like I said was seven
yeah that's old enough to know what the
hell's going on and then the youngest
one was six months I think Mary was six
months old so she did the three younger
boys she she drowned each one of them
and then she took them in the bedroom
and like laid them out on the bed and
like put sheets over them
and then she drowned the baby
and then she went to get her oldest kid
Noah who was seven
Noah comes in the bathroom and sees the
baby floating dead in the tub and says
what's wrong with Mary
and then he realizes what's going on and
he runs yeah and Andrea chases him
through the house
and grabbed him and like took him in the
and drowned him in the tub like while
the dead baby was floating yeah so she's
held his head on right there yeah [__]
is that all he said he didn't say
anything else huh I think I heard that
he said I'm sorry hmm like he thought
that he had done something bad
um man
so the creepy thing about this so she
systematically does this like the hour
after Rusty leaves her work and then
before her mom gets there
she calls the cops immediately
and that you you can hear the 911 call
it's on YouTube
and she just has this very flat affect
and she basically says she doesn't tell
them what the problem is she just says I
need a police officer to come
and the 911 dispatcher says well what
you know what's the matter like what do
you need them for I just need them to
come and they're like well is your
husband there is he is somebody standing
there like not letting you talk or
something like that no I just need and
then they're like are you ill and then
she says yeah I'm Ill and then they're
like well do you need an ambulance no I
need a police officer yeah send an
ambulance
and then when the cops got there she
basically opened the door and told them
what she did she just told him straight
out
now
when they took her into custody
she basically said and there's footage
of this like I watched the footage of
her because she just looks
pitiful I mean she just looks sick her
hair is just all stringy she looks like
she's like not really there you know
what I mean
she tells the cops that
basically I'm kind of paraphrasing
but she said her kids were not righteous
and that they were going to it was
something like she thought that they
were gonna go to hell
unless she did something about it kind
of thing
so it was almost like she believed
they were bad
yeah and she believed that she was like
saving them yeah by killing them she
really did seem to believe that and she
also seemed to believe that she was evil
and that by killing them she was gonna
send them to heaven and then she would
go to she would get the death penalty
and she would go to hell
um like as Penance like so they could go
to heaven she kind of believed that okay
so
she used religious ideology
as a vehicle to get this done
she's malfunctioning she's going to kill
the kids yeah
so she has to make up a a reason
and you know
because of the religion she kind of put
peace peace to narrative together she's
saving them
yeah she's saving them she's bad she's
good there's something wrong with her so
she's going to be punished
yeah okay yeah
of course she's [__] off her [__]
rocker yeah and like I said it's not
really
it doesn't seem like her fault I mean
obviously she had severe issues from
when she was young yeah she's [__]
trying to get help and they're not
helping her really well not really her
husband is
not understanding
the problem and then not helping that's
I'm look man I gotta say I gotta blame
the husband
I kind of do too maybe he didn't know
any better
I'm gonna tell you you're a dumb
[__] you're just stupid
you should have known man
the doctors told you
but he thought he knew about I thought
he knew better there's something in his
ideology well you know Jesus wouldn't
let that happen or some [__] like
that
and I I have a Christian [__]
background all right so it's
you can't come crying to me
that's some [__] weird cult
stuff and uh sounds like really more
selfish than anything else oh because
you want a quiverful family because you
think that that's what God is commanding
you to do
probably more like it's magnifying your
own ego look at how many kids I have
you're in common well that's exactly
what it is in competition with other
dudes in your cult how many kids you
know you think you're [__] Noah or
[__] Abraham and you're not all right
you're douche yeah pretty much yeah look
at all my sperms right you got a decent
job
you could have had your woman in style
with all these kids there's a girl just
as a girl just up the street here's got
[__] nine of them and she's [__]
having a good time got a big old house
kids are having fun you know so you can
do that but you just can't stick them in
a goddamn trailer
I mean like I said you know you gotta
have a bunch of kids yeah it's just like
any other kind of wild animal if you're
gonna own a [__] lions or [__]
Tigers we got those [__] up the
road here too [__] breeding big cats
they got habitats for all that if you're
gonna have a big family you gotta have a
[__] habitat for that
yeah and get your wife some help get her
some [__] girls to come in that's
what I mean she needs to probably have
afforded yeah to help like hire her a
nanny or a maid or something yeah like
you can't do that by yourself they got
12 13 14 year old girls that'll come
over and [__] take care of the kids
and help them help them Mama out I know
I was raised in the conditions like that
my mom was constantly passing me off to
Kimmy and I [__] love Kimmy she was
like Little Princess Leia and she was
about 13. take me to the movies and
stuff well I grew up like my my parents
both of my parents always worked you
know because they were broke and they
needed money so they were always working
so we just mostly spent the time with
our grandparents like yeah we stayed
with our grandparents all the time well
I was just fine with me my grandparents
weren't around there you know we were
out in California at that time and it
was just a whole block full of
kids of different ages and you know my
parents were in their 20s at that time
and they wanted to have a night out you
know whatever they just hand me over to
Kimmy yeah and Kimmy was about 13. take
me to the [__] all-girl slumber
parties and [__] [__] listening to
Led Zeppelin and crap back in the 70s
you know so I was [__] in hog heaven
I mean the thing about it look raising
children even under the best of
circumstances is a difficult it's
difficult
and having that having five children
and not really having any support
network not having an identity of your
own like I said it really does seem like
Rusty kind of made her
give up her own because like I said
prior to that she had a job you know she
had her own apartment she probably I
presume she had friends she had other
things like that you can't that's
another thing is that I feel like some
like sometimes when you have kids like
people just expect you to like just oh
now you're just Mom and you're not like
you anymore yeah no it's not a house and
that's really not I mean you you need
your own me time it's not selfish or
anything like that you're still a person
like monotony will be separate from them
not and it will drive you crazy no
matter how you sure and if you got any
weaknesses in you it'll even be more
yeah but you know usually women that
have big families have a varied
experience
you know what I mean they're they're not
doing just that you know what I mean
yeah I would hope not because you need a
[__] break everybody needs a break no
matter what you do yeah you know
relatives come over and help yeah local
girls come over and help and it just
seemed to me that Andrea didn't have any
help yeah she was just expected to do
everything the story of another mom
coming over and hanging out with her
like her mom came over sometimes to help
no I'm talking about usually what
happened oh right here bombs come and
bring their kids together and they go
yeah and they all just like yeah the
women are hanging out and the kids are
hanging out you know I mean so it's a
big like uh it's a big event you know
yeah which is good you know that's
that's a good idea because you've got
friends who are in the same situation
and they're just bonding over being moms
and with all these kids you know so I
don't understand what Rusty's [__]
issue was but it [__] paid the
price cost him a family yeah they paid
for his stupidity if you ask me he
[__] stupid yeah so I put selfishness
yeah I put this on I put part of it on
on Rusty I do as well dumb [__]
and like I said she was clearly it would
be different okay I'm not saying it
would be necessarily better it would
have been different if Andrea for
example had been that severely mentally
ill but hid it from everybody but the
thing about it was that she wasn't
hiding it I mean she very clearly had
several nervous breakdowns she had
several uh suicide attempts she was in
and out of psychiatric hospitals she
basically said outright I'm afraid I'm
gonna hurt my children
um you know and she said that she'd had
all these horrible thoughts about it and
it had thoughts about it for years and
had kind of been planning it and it was
like making her it was causing her a lot
of distress and it seemed like Rusty was
not really taking it all that seriously
is what I'm saying
um I think he thought that she could
just snap out of it
um but mental illness that's severe you
can't really snap out of it which you
get I mean and it just goes to show that
like the drugs that they when they
finally did get her on a cocktail of
drugs like antidepressants and
antipsychotics and stuff that actually
worked for her and Rusty even said oh my
God she's like back to normal like when
I first met her
um you know that should have continued
but no Rusty had to have another kid no
you have to have more babies so go off
all your medication and you know that's
what [__] happened so I you know
yeah she's the one that did it and it's
horrible and it's and just like hearing
about it just made my [__] stomach
clench it was just it was awful
and I'm not excusing it
um but I'm just saying that the
situation was just [__]
tragic all around it was just it and it
could have been avoided it could have
been avoided that's the most tragic
thing because she did ask for help and
it just seemed like she didn't really
get it or she didn't really get it
you know in a timely fashion that could
have like saved those children it didn't
have to happen you know
but it's it's just [__] up it's just
like it's really one of the saddest
cases that I've ever read about because
I you know in the Susan Smith case like
we
we don't really feel bad for her I mean
because it seemed like she did the [__]
for just selfish cold selfish reasons as
much as he didn't as much as there was
no warning yeah this one had a lot of
warning signs that's what I'm saying
they've been prevented yeah because like
I said she had had numerous nervous
breakdowns numerous times in psychiatric
hospitals you know numerous visits for
psychiatrists psychiatrists who knew
that she was having these thoughts about
harming her children and he's telling
her she's gonna have more kids so she's
got no even after the psychiatrist
specifically said please please please
yeah yeah so he's piling more stress on
her but he's like well that's what women
do
that's that's that's their job that's
their job that's what he really didn't
seem to think that that's the women's
role because that whole biblical thing
yeah because that's what he read and
he's like well that's their role so it's
like so if you can't do it then you must
be defective in some way I guess that's
probably what he was thinking what's
funny is that they're always going to
the Old Testament and every story in the
Old Testament is an allegory to another
religion that was kind of had become
defunct by the Canaanites you know in
the Judaism you know in other words like
I saw one one analysis that Abraham
actually was the story of Abraham was
modeled after an older religion that
Canaanites believed it and and the gods
of that religion kind of got demoted
into Patriarchs and the founders so the
uh because they didn't want to throw
their old religion away they just
reinterpreted it as which that kind of
makes sense it's just
like comic book nerds
fighting over what's Canon and what
isn't Canon hey don't throw that out
that's the original old Star Wars New
Hope don't throw that out we'll just put
that into it we'll just re put change
the narrative and put that in there
still you know so just because
Old Testament Patriarchs were described
as that doesn't mean that those guys
ever even existed
you know so you're trying to emulate
mythological characters
like there was no Moses
it's a mythological character
there was no Abraham
there was no Cain or Abel
so why are you trying this is all
mythology
and you're trying to shoehorn like
people's actual lives into mythology
into yeah story a fictional stories
fiction stories
to teach morals or to or to give an
explanation of where certain things came
from you know there are each one of
those stories has different meaning to
it
but uh there was no Moses
no I don't believe that no
like I said they were all just like but
it was like comic books like yeah
Jeff yard said I doubt Rusty cared about
his former family when he remarried yeah
it each seems like that kind of dude
he's just like oh well
I'll get another one well the devil got
him or some [__] like that or probably
that's what it was God's will yeah
so the thing okay so Andrea obviously
did not hide the fact that she had
killed her children and she was quite
open about saying that she thought that
it was because like I said essentially
she
thought that she was saving them or or
that they weren't righteous and that she
had failed and that she was evil and
that that was the only way that she
could redeem anyone
was by eliminating them
so she confessed to that
um they put her on trial they were gonna
try and get uh Not Guilty by reason of
insanity defense but like I said this is
Texas uh it's very very difficult that's
a very high bar to clear particularly in
Texas
and basically the only criteria being
you know you had to know uh that you you
had to not know what you were doing was
wrong and in 2001 at her first trial
um the jury
didn't think that she was technically
like the legal definition of insane
so they actually found her guilty of
murder
and um they were going to uh they were
gonna do they're gonna try and do the
death penalty like they did uh Susan
Smith but Jerry said no we don't want to
go that far so they didn't do that but
they sentenced her to life in prison
um with parole eligibility after 40
years however in 2006
her conviction was actually
um reversed it was overturned
because of this weird little detail I
mean it wasn't weird because it would
have been like prejudicial at the
initial trial
they discovered that one of the
psychiatrists who had um testified for
the prosecution his name was Dr Park
Dietz
he had actually given testimony during
the first trial in 2001.
that perhaps Andrea had gotten the idea
to kill her children and then try to get
an insanity defense from an episode of
Law and Order in which a woman drowned
her kids and then got off with an
insanity defense and he said that at the
trial which like I said it doesn't sound
like much because like oh she just saw
it on a TV show but that is very
prejudicial against the defendant
and they discovered that this episode of
Law and Order did not exist
there was later an episode of Law and
Order that was Loosely based on the
Andrea Yates case but that was two years
later so they're like so there's no way
that she could have seen a Law and Order
episode I mean he I don't know if he
made it up or if he just misremembered
something like and he was just pulling
it out of his butt but because of that
testimony that he'd given the conviction
was overturned and they gave her a new
trial in 2006 because like I said they
thought that it could be prejudicial
because that didn't exist so it's like
she couldn't have got the idea from a TV
show that didn't exist you know what I
mean so they actually redid the trial in
2006. and at this trial
uh the jury found that the uh definition
of insanity was met they determined that
she did
it was almost kind of like yeah she knew
what she was doing was wrong kind of but
it's like she wasn't really in her right
mind and she had like delusional reasons
for doing what she did you know what I
mean so it's like they thought that that
met the criteria so they allowed her to
do uh you know they they came back with
that verdict like Not Guilty by reason
of insanity but they under the
stipulation that she be sent to a mental
hospital which is what happened so they
actually did send her to a mental
hospital later on like a few years later
uh they sent her to a lower security one
and as far as I know she is still there
to that to this day like she's still
there and she does not appear to want to
get out even though they have said that
she may petition to be released uh not
necessarily that she will be but they
said she can petition but she always
waives the right to do so she does not
seem to want to get out she's happy
where she's at that's what I mean she
seems to be doing all right where she's
at and how old would she be now
um let's see
oh I don't know
we coming into back into society after
this much time it'd be pretty traumatic
for somebody who's been in there for
that long but she probably has afraid to
come out and she's probably
pretty comfortable and live in a pretty
uh regimented regimented existence you
know what I mean and that's might be
good for her she might have friends in
there you know and have little friends
yeah I mean she does have like
psychiatrists and stuff like that she
has like friends in there like people
that come and visit her yeah and she
does seem to be doing all right all
right and she was uh as a religious uh
background so she's probably seeing this
as Penance that she shouldn't yeah I I
definitely do think because she does
seem to have that mindset and she
probably still has that after all this
time is that she seemed to genuinely
believe that she was the devil yeah that
Satan was inside her I think I'd let her
out and that
um I think I let her out actually even
though she's the one that [__] upset
me the most I probably let her out well
like I said she's not she's not a threat
and uh like I said take control of her
faculty right this is why this case is
complex like obviously what she did was
[__] horrific I mean just like
thinking about it just makes me want to
scream she was mentally ill but she
couldn't
I don't think she could help it yeah and
there were so many other like the female
cats
when you have litters and they put them
under a bunch of stress they go crazy
and kill their own kittens
I've heard of it never seen it but they
say that they do but they're in an
unsafe environment
and I don't really make big distinctions
between humans and animals I believe
that they're the same uh I mean to an
extent the only difference is that is is
the is the proportions in other words
like some of them have humans have a
little bit more
logic and intelligence than other
animals but not that much more
no the difference in the genes between a
human and a champ is not that much just
small just a small tweak makes a much
bigger brain
but animals are conscious too they have
feelings you know what I mean and they
do weird things and humans do things
basically according to programming you
know you can break your programming if
you understand it but you're still not
as free as you think you are
and and we may not actually be all that
conscious
we think we are but a spider might think
it is too
yeah they don't really know so
that's kind of why even though you know
having background and hunting and [__]
like that you know I'm always very
um uh
cautious about what kind of animals I'll
kill for food you know I don't believe
in trapping and
um only prey animals like deer and
things that
propagating large numbers I'm not into
this [__] like killing cats like you
know I mean Bobcats and coyote or those
are dogs and cats man they just happen
to be living outside without the wild
you know what I mean yeah so um
you know even when it comes to animals
you got to be careful because you know
they do have little personalities yeah
you know I feel bad if I hit a raccoon
you know what I mean the raccoons are
Charming little things you know more
intelligent than a cat kind of
monkey-like and friendly they're not me
now you get one cornered and you try to
grab it yeah you're gonna get two or
tore the [__] up you know well I mean
that'll happen
you know what I mean there's a lot of
videos of raccoons that come in people's
houses and beg for food and they're let
you pet them once they get to know you
you know and they're nice little
creatures
uh humans I put are all in that same
Spectrum
you know we're not that different from
them
and made what happened to her is
something that you would kind of kind of
reminds me of something I'd see in the
animal kingdom
where you got a female she's in a bad
environment she's unhealthy which kind
of is another additional Factor she
doesn't have good mental health
and she can't solve this problem that
she's having
so she self-destructs yeah destroy
destroys her litter
yeah it's like something a cat would do
like I said that's kind of it was just a
conflation of like the worst possible
circumstances she rationalizes it to mix
a narrative around why she's doing the
religious motifs and [__] but animals
are probably making a weird motifs and
explanations of why they're doing what
they're doing
don't don't underestimate animals
animals kind of have feelings they can
think and they they can imagine things
because you see a cat playing with
something imagining it's a it's it's a
it's a lizard you know I know what
Pookie's imagining so they can imagine
you may not be imagined they're not
imagined correctly you know but I think
when a cat is killing her litter you
know I think it's just like these babies
won't make it because I'm you know under
threat
so and I think that's probably exactly
yeah what Andrea was yeah because I have
to run and I can't leave these here
they'll just starve until it kills them
the cat kills them yeah
you know and yeah it was something like
that but she comes up with a creative
way yeah I mean that's what humans do
they rationalize their actions that's
kind of what I'm imagining I mean that
sounds like pretty plausible because
like I said it was just like a a perfect
storm of shitty circumstances Not only
was did she have a long history of
mental illness which like I said was no
secret like everybody knew about it but
then she ended up in this situation that
just made it worse and worse and worse
and worse and like I said to her credit
she knew it was getting worse she seemed
cognizant of it and was trying to get
help it wasn't like she was trying to
keep it from anybody she was trying to
like she's trapped she can't get out
between these different forces so she's
a woman that's been kind of stripped of
any choice and she's being told that
she's gonna have more and more children
which means the pressure is going to
Mountain There's No Escape yeah so she
has to get she's in danger she's got to
get rid of the litter in herself and
she's got to come up with some kind of
weird yeah
that's probably exactly what was and
then like you know after the after after
the homicides are over she now is
calling for the police which is the
ultimate help and they'll take her away
yeah
and she definitely felt like she
deserved to be taken away yeah which is
why I think she doesn't want to ever get
out of mental hospital because she
reinterprets us that she's going to pay
pennants for her sin yeah which an
animal might do that in a certain way
you don't know what what and we don't
know what the
internal world of an animal is like but
I'm sure they're thinking things like
that but more like a child yeah would
think of it you know
yeah I definitely think like the way
that the way that Pookie interacts and
stuff like that Pookie's our cat if
you're new yeah
um facial expressions she basically I
mean she comes across like a like a kid
like a toddler yeah she does the same
things that a kid would do she can
deceive like a kid would
you know you can tell what she wants
just like the way a kid would you could
read facial expressions yeah like she
can't talk talk but you know what she
you surprise anger
you know uh you can see no or yes like
no no
no I don't understand
so that means that there's an internal
world yeah of ideas yeah imagination
there's an internal dialogue happening
in in there and I imagine there's all
kinds there's definitely imagination
should be waiting for us by the door
yeah
so they'll be back here they'll be back
so that's Faith right there so there's a
lot of advanced stuff
yeah when you really think about it yeah
yeah I have faith that they will be back
so you know
it's weird
like you said I don't think there's a
huge Gulf but no
the way that humans think the difference
is just in proportions yeah and like I
said humans are a lot better at
rationalizing yeah and picking up
excuses they're weird ass Behavior but
to be here like later on but to behave
your the default Behavior especially in
younger people is animal very much so
the guys act like male animals of any
other species it's just
it's just more dressed up the same thing
with all the females and stuff it's hard
to break your own programming and it
it's only because what you're programmed
to do sometimes doesn't work anymore
because you've inherited mechanisms and
programs from
that are so old and so ancient
they're not even human ancestors that
you inherited that from you know
just other mammals yeah
Jeffy Hart said how tragically ironic
that she's getting better care than she
was with her husband or in that religion
yeah yeah it is very sad
all the women of that religion though
didn't work like this it was that
particular one
and and she was weak I mean it seemed
like I don't know how many followers
this weird Street Preacher had they
showed on this documentary that I was
watching about her
um they showed like some footage of this
loon yeah like the and he would like him
and his family because I guess he was
family and some of his followers and
they would just like go out in the
street and like dress up in silly
costumes and they were one of those ones
that were they're kind of like
Westborough Baptist Church it seemed
like they were kind of like that kind of
crazy although that's not a real Church
well I mean you know what I mean they've
been trying to get law lawsuits yeah but
it was kind of like that sort of thing
yeah Victor says my hamster ate her
babies yeah I had a hamster that did
that too yeah that's pretty common and I
think it's because they're it's the
stress of like them being in these
little cages and yeah and they go
there's no future for these yeah it
happens a lot actually so like like you
said I think that was like um a good way
of putting it that might have been the
situation here yeah what was going on
here oh I forgot to mention that another
thing that Rusty like other than making
her have babies all the time make her
live in a [__] 350 foot bus yeah was
that um he told her that she was only
allowed two hours a week to do what she
wanted the rest of the time she had to
be serving yeah she's he's full of [__]
no that just full of [__] that's what
it's funny he was probably making really
good money I mean he must have been I
wonder where all that money went
hookers and Below yeah hookers and blow
probably how much you want to bet he had
girlfriends
those type of dudes always do yeah it
seems like there's like oh I want to
knock this woman up and have her have
all my [__] crotch fruit yeah and
then like have her stay home and clean
up my house and wash [__] diapers and
stuff but I'm gonna go out and stick my
dick in whatever how much you want to
bet oh boy
had a uh a mistress in a nice apartment
that he spent a lot of time with her it
would not Shock me to be honest that
would that would be right on brand yeah
and then he's got his brood mirror
living in that damn bus yeah
like [__] holy man
because it's always those types of dudes
are always like that yeah because they
feel like this versus 22 right yeah
because they feel like oh well I'm
righteous so they can do whatever the
[__] they want to like you said they
always like justify well if you have if
you're if you're if you're an Old
Testament patriarch not only do you have
[__] a quiverful family you got
multiple wives right and it's totally
okay it's right there in the Bible yeah
yeah it says I can do it so you know
it's allowed and you can't [__] about
it woman yeah you knew men wrote that
[__]
well duh yeah
that's what yeah when I read the Bible
when I was like young because I felt
like I should even though I was an
atheist from a young age but like I was
like well I should probably read it and
I read the whole thing and I was like
yeah men wrote this [__] yeah that's for
sure well I think I was like no thanks
I'm not going along with this I think uh
polyamory is the default setting for men
actually uh they'll if left to their own
devices they'll collect a whole Harem of
women and they'll love them all
but but
you gotta understand there's limits to
[__] and [__] come on you know
well and at least Islam which they've
they've [__] ratified they had said
yeah you can do that they said but you
got to be limited to three and you gotta
treat them all equally
and you got all got to keep them in
separate houses
before you could do that
so that means only Rich guys can do it
you know so at least they thought of
that it says you can't have nine of them
up in the same [__] house
you know you're just asking for Trump
yes but travel there they're gonna gang
up on you anyway you know all right
although the Mormons were some of those
Mormon Cults were doing that not raw
Mormon yeah the Mormon Cults were doing
that yeah we did a whole show on that
some of these dudes in their [__] 90s
with like [__] 30 teenage wives and
[__] it's [__] up and then those girls
don't even know what sex is no how would
they were raised in a completely like
isolated just 90 Something Beautiful
environment living skeleton is going
come on baby let's make love like what
the [__] is that you know what I mean
and they're just totally you know like
what the hell's going what is wrinkly
all doing coming at you gross damn but
that's what I mean it's like well the
thing that kills me
is that look I have no problem with
polyamory in general or anything like
that is like I said as long as
everybody's on the same page yeah you
can do whatever you want problem is that
a lot of these dudes like the Mormons
and like a lot of these weird
fundamentalists Cults like the Duggars
and all that kind of [__] is their whole
thing is like oh well the women have to
stay home and serve us and be bread
mares and stuff but we can do whatever
they but they can't they can't though
right they can't though yeah and I was
like well that's where I draw the line
right like I said you can do anything
sexually you're gonna have polyamory
then the women everybody too they want
also so I don't that's what I don't the
hypocrisy is what I don't like I don't
like this whole well I can do what I
want but you can yeah and that that's
[__] that's one thing I can give
tony naleda that's my ex and the guy
that I never registered to yeah they're
great they're great but they're they're
they're polyamorous they go to swinger
clubs and [__] like that they're trying
to get us to go all the time they
videotape it and [__] send us [__]
loud okay whatever we've seen at least
with them
it's just wide open yeah she can date
whoever she wants he dates whoever
that's what I mean everybody's on the
same page it's fine yeah I have no
problem with that kind of stuff as long
as everybody as long as somebody's going
behind somebody's back as long as
nobody's like as long as it's not one
person thinking it's one way and then
this other person's doing this other
[__] it's not so much the sex that I
that I'm that I disapprove of it's the
lying yeah like the Betrayal lying but
also the like all right it's Saturday
night you stay here I'm gonna go out
right you know what I mean if I can go
out with my girlfriend and who are you
going you're not going okay you stay
here they do that though I don't I don't
really I'm like man I I couldn't do that
to Jen
we're going to the club what are you
gonna do because you're not coming with
us
I just couldn't do that but I would
punch you right in your face but they do
that yeah it'd be different if like
we're all going
yeah that's what I mean it's like if it
was that situation yeah it will all go
as a group yeah like you know it's all
everybody's it's all about the party you
know what I mean like I said I have no
problem with that at all I just don't
like I just don't like the people having
like different expectations or like some
people thinking oh well I thought it was
like this and it's not like that like I
just couldn't even if it was the open
surgery I couldn't leave my woman at
home
like you stay here I'm going to dinner
with [__] Sally
I just couldn't I just couldn't do that
Sally of the Sally Beauty Empire yeah
yeah I don't know why I thought about it
I don't understand how they do it but I
guess they don't get jealous I don't
know
I would I know it later though I figured
she's probably I would probably [__]
burn her ass up that [__]
well see I kind of put and I know that
all not not all women are the same yeah
and I know that there are a lot of women
that are into the whole polyamory thing
they say that they don't really give a
[__] but I kind of I don't know I always
kind of feel like whenever there's like
a polyamory or like a transition I
always feel like I was like was that the
dude's idea I feel like it was probably
the dude's idea and like she just went
along with it she's like meh okay I know
that's not I know that's not the case
you know when I was going out with her
shoes like that
yeah I'm not saying that's the case in
her situation I'm just saying that I A
lot of times like we've known for people
we've known some people that were in
like
um you know like kind of Triad
situations and I always got the
suspicious I always had the suspicion
that it was like the dude's fault or
like the dude's idea yeah well the
dude's fault the dude's idea and like
she just went along with it just to make
him happy and but she didn't really like
it and then the girls start fighting
right so I I always just kind of feel
like that happens and we know
um a couple of couples that have been in
long-term Triads yeah like not with the
same person but it's like different ones
there's a couple but then they always
have like a different third yeah there's
a married couple that always has a
girlfriend yeah and they they last year
and they do last years like but they're
you know successive but they but they
live they all live together though right
right
they'll have one that lives with them
for like a year or two or something like
that and they'll all go out together
yeah and stuff like that but even they
said that the main problem was the it's
is always jealousy they're always like
it's usually like the third person will
come in and we'll want to like kind of
take over the [__] or there's always
kind of that trying to get rid of the
original one yeah like that kind of
stuff so there's always that kind of
jockeying for position but in that
situation it's not him it's her
yeah she likes the girls yeah she's
bringing them in yeah she's the one
bringing them she can't live without him
right so they always have one yeah he's
kind of
he's like okay whatever he just you know
yeah he's kind of I don't know he's not
indifferent but he's just kind of like
oh well okay
bonus put his [__]
she's cool yeah just like that yeah he's
not right but it's not him though it's
her yeah it's her but like I said it
that's an unusual situation yeah and
they've been doing that for years they
might be older than we are yeah they've
been doing that as long as we've known
we've known him for 14 years at least
yeah yeah
but yeah and they were doing it a long
time before we met him so like I said
it's it's not so much like what people
do it's just the fact that if everyone's
adults and everyone is on the same page
and everybody knows what the situation
is and everyone is okay with it no one's
being coerced into anything or nothing
like that then it's fine do whatever the
[__] I still couldn't go on a solo
date and leave my girlfriend back home
well I would hope not no I couldn't do
it I would be mad if you did that yeah I
think you would be mad if I did that
yeah yeah I think anybody would well I
wouldn't do that anyway yeah I think
anybody would if you're gonna if you're
gonna start doing polyamory it's it's a
big family everybody's together all the
time well if you're gonna start doing
this I'm a big advocate of it if you're
gonna do that yeah then you need to like
get together and have like a serious
talk and be like is everybody like and
what are the parameters of this like
what are the rules because there have to
be rules you can't just do the [__]
whatever it's like what are the
expectations yeah
um you know so you really have to have
like a long discussion about that kind
of [__] like before you get into like oh
are we gonna bring another person into
this like if you're are you gonna open
the relationship up you have to like
know like what all the programs the
cases that we're talking about the girls
are all bisexual yeah okay so it's not
like there isn't any exclusivity in the
relationships they're all doing each
other
but they're also going on solo dates
that's weird yeah Tom thinks that's
weird well that's the weird part to me
yeah not so much to sex well because
that's all happening together yeah yeah
it's just like okay you stay here we're
gonna we're going out we're going to
this club right you're not invited
you're just stay home and wait for us to
come home well that's what I need to go
get another date like this sort of [__]
like that the second you told me I
wasn't invited somewhere I'd be like bye
dude what the [__]
I don't like that I do not yeah I don't
like being left out yeah yeah I would
feel left out as a [__] I gotta
stay here while she's out with dude or
the girl whatever right you know I
wouldn't do that to you that's right
Beverly you're gonna go [__] I gotta
stay here I gotta go to another club I'm
gonna hang out the [__] Oasis what
the [__]
with the bikers like I said I just think
that's a shitty thing to do in general
whether it's just like your partner like
your friend or whatever I just I don't
like leaving people out and I don't like
being left out either right so it's like
I wouldn't do that to somebody else
because that's like a shitty thing to do
to somebody
so you know what I mean like I said if
everybody's okay with it fine but I
would think it was weird and Jenna
messed around we never did that [__] we
were always all together yeah like I
said I would never do that yeah it's
just not something that would ever occur
to me to be honest it's just not
something I would do although the girls
were told I didn't have any expectations
of us just come get go get her go get
her go to Club
yeah that's what he demands on us yeah
it was just and it was just kind of like
a situation where oh we you know we went
out everyone was just kind of drinking
and it's like oh let's go back to it and
then everybody was having a good time
you know what I mean it wasn't like any
kind of yeah we also just considered
them buddies too right it wasn't really
yeah it's not like anybody's gonna steal
anybody or nothing like that it was just
everybody was kind of drinking and we
were having a good time and laughing at
each other right it was just that kind
of situation it wasn't like anything
super serious but you know all right
um
she was kissed by a fire said I made a
throuple in The Sims talk about tons of
drama that's what I mean I'm always just
kind of like I admire people that can
keep that going for a really long time
because I'm like holy [__] like just
being in a relationship with one other
person I mean that's
a job in itself kind of I mean you know
it just depends on what it's not a job
but I'm just saying that it's like
that's it's you know a lot to deal with
but it's like and then bringing a third
person in with all of those Dynamics
um you know that's always going to be
Tonya later it's not three it's like
four or five Yeah well yeah and I can't
imagine different Sexes so it's uh
I guess it's kind of like not being in a
relationship
yeah I mean if there's that many people
it's just kind of like a big group
you're just living together and just
doing whatever you want to do right so
it's just kind of like with it even with
a species of person that thinks like
that and they're all just kind of like
that yeah yeah which like I said it's
you know some people are like that and
that's fine I'm not really built for
that I'm not either it's not really my
thing yeah that's too too [__] for me
you're [__] but you're not that I'm
sweaty I'm not desolate like I said like
we've we've you know messed around with
that but it's just kind of like not just
like as together and like nothing
seriously you know what I mean like no
long term like I said we're just kind of
like [__] around yeah just because we
were out and it was fun yeah but we
didn't like try to build a relationship
around no no like it wasn't even that
wasn't even considered yeah you know
what I mean but yeah I'm just I'm just
not really that kind of person I guess
but no judgment if like some people
because I know some people are but I'm
not and you're not either really no no I
like that yeah
like I said I was just take it out funny
it would be I'm mad if I came in
tomorrow and said hey I'm going on a
date with uh I don't know Dave or
something like that I don't know you're
like what you stay here or go go
somewhere else don't come to the club
don't yeah don't don't [__] yeah you
might see something you're cramping my
style
can you imagine
but I just came and I told you that
that is cold as [__] oh [__] blood
that is cold as
but but yeah all right so it's getting
pretty late I gotta go to bed soon
because I gotta get up early but uh yeah
so hopefully yeah you guys enjoyed this
show this evening we mostly kind of
stayed on topic which I'm impressed by
us even though we've been on for a while
we've been on for three hours yeah but
yeah so uh cool hopefully you guys enjoy
this I know it's a very depressing topic
but I mean I found it interesting so
hopefully you guys found it interesting
too so yeah the next time we're gonna
stream is our Sidetrack show which is
gonna be Friday night so that should be
fun we'll have some drinks and talk
about some more [__] all right talk
about what we did on streaming talk
about streaming
because I know that's what the Side
Drive show is going to be coming like
stories from streamate because we
streamed on there last night not for
very long though we were just only on
for like an hour hour 15 or something
like that because I was kind of tired
I've been at work all day but um but
yeah so weird we didn't it wasn't that
crazy well I don't know we do it was
funny it was like kind of funny so we
might talk about that on Friday pick up
a quick 25 bucks yeah it's kind of well
it's kind of cool that you can just kind
of hop on there and just be like hey
let's do a couple like [__] [__]
little shows real quick yeah 25 bucks
and then like for less than an hour for
about 10 minutes 20 minutes worth of
work yeah then it's just like oh okay
well that was 25 bucks I didn't have
before so it's nice I got my first check
from there today yeah yeah
so that was kind of cool so they sent a
check every week if you have over a
certain amount so I was like that's nice
I was I was waiting to see because it
took a while for it to hit that [__]
full time we'd make a lot of money
yeah I mean eventually we're talking
about that yeah like because I would
actually like to segue into that as soon
as possible and do like do it like a
full-time job yeah you know what I mean
and then yeah because we've been
streaming
um we wanted to go on there a few times
like at different times like of the day
different days of the week and see if it
was consistent like a consistent amount
of money per hour you know what I mean
yeah it is and it does seem to be yeah
so I was like so even when it's real
slow I mean you usually like 20 an hour
is like Baseline like so a lot of times
you make more than that but I was like
well as long as it's at least that then
we could do this full-time and it would
be Bill's wife my friend Bill his wife
is uh her name is Amy Quinn you can look
her up she's a porn star
streams and she's not a big porn star
she's a local one
there's a lot of her out there though
um she's she streams
30 hours a week I'm gonna have to say
how much she makes but he told me it's a
lot yeah and then
he said Rock Bottom average is 20 an
hour that's the Rock Bottom average
which is not bad at all in the winter
time at certain hours it's ninety
dollars an hour yeah because there's
just a lot of traffic in there but
because it's summer there isn't a lot of
traffic
yeah we kind of hit a slow period but
even then it's like every time we go on
WE generally average about 20 an hour or
a little bit more at 30 hours
at 30 hours a week she makes six figures
yeah
it's about twice what what Jen's bacon
right yeah at my regular job yeah so
like I said very tempting it is well
and you gotta approach it like a job and
we're the right kind of people for it in
terms of the disa work discipline and
yeah I mean I would keep you in line
well look it's like I've run this [__]
for since 2016. keeping everybody on
schedule keeping everything doing all
the doing all the research doing all the
cards and setting everything up and all
that other kind of lighting and sets
which we have costumes [__] uh what
do you call it uh
audio visual editing skills so we have
all that graphic design
and we're also going to move on to other
platforms like minivids and stuff
because we have a bunch of video
material that we can't sell on streaming
yeah
we got we got a pretty decent catalog
built up yeah we've been shooting
it's pretty good stuff yeah like on the
weekends we usually shoot like a video
yeah
yeah so but someone was funny
but yeah so like I said we'll probably
talk about that more on Friday we can
talk about like what we did on there I
don't know if we're gonna stream
tomorrow night or not like on stream 8
but we'll see how I feel when I get home
I might be too tired but we'll see all
right kiss bye fire thanks for catching
live yeah I'm glad you came by glad all
of you guys came back but yeah so thanks
for hanging out with us this evening
thanks for super chats and all that and
we'll see you guys again on Friday night
for the Sidetrack show good night